two Hello everybody welcome it's
Wednesday April 5th a beautiful sunny
day in Spring Isn't it nice it's spring
yes it's beautiful I'm joined speaking
of spring
here is my my beautiful son Bruce is
here go ahead say la la to everybody
thank you good yeah the K the kids are
all here today uh they're on well
Teddy's on spring break which is two
weeks by the way
and so the kids are here the dogs are
here expect lots of interruptions
Brucie just got his Kermit the Frog my
maternal grandmother
rubbed her
would you like to hear about my dreams
no no and Bruce don't get me started on
postmodernistic Marxism yeah I'm telling
you brother you gotta you gotta watch
out the world is a scary place
especially for a man like you
you gotta hold on to your rights
and never give in to the dragon energy
of both female it's so true
listen to what I'm saying Miss Piggy is
a perfect allegory for the evils of
women oh that's so true
is that written right now that [__]
tried to ruin my life baby sad and I'm
here despite her little Brucie
and I'll have you know
I'll have you know Bruce she will not
have me oh Bruce if you could turn the
mic back up Mercy Mike etiquette Mike
etiquette
let me tell you about my maternal
grandmother Bruce Judy
she let her she let me have her way
hey yeah so uh welcome everybody we have
a fun show here today of course
perching
really fun show finally uh Olivia has
prepared a 60 slide
Olivia's prepared to 83 uh slide
presentation about the Selena Gomez
versus Haley Bieber drama or is it it's
more than her now it's translated bigger
than all of us bigger than all of us
that is true and um because of the
length of it you can go ahead and show
the set we've prepared
we are going to assemble a America's Got
Talent Style
and
no Jubilee style right Jubilee Jubilee
Jubilee yeah I've never heard of that is
that there's some examples in the dock
yeah oh the YouTube channel exactly yes
so she gonna keep going and then
we're gonna have the opportunity to buzz
her uh with peace and love of course we
need a there's gonna be seven of us in
the audience you want your Kermit here
oh
and if the majority we need a four-man
person majority to scoot to do the big
comically oversized cane on Olivia
I would not be doing this if I didn't
think that there was so much evidence
that proved that you guys weren't super
sure what you were talking about when
you were saying that people were
reaching during the drama and I was like
you guys have to know that this goes
back so far so I I pull the actual
evidence that I hope is compelling
enough so your thesis is that there's no
overreaching the drama is real that's my
thesis it's just that people were not
being crazy when they said that's a
little sus okay okay well I per you know
me I love the the drama I can't imagine
that I'm gonna be buzzing you thank you
so much exactly Zach is a known hostile
towards the drama yeah I'm scared to
talk to Zach about this I've been
hearing about it trying to unplug our
cameras you could grab them Abby gets
angry whenever the job starts to speak
about this so I just I just take your
career sorry very quickly take your car
man I just want to be clear that's my
Kermit I'm letting him borrow it it's
fine it's fine but sharing Zach is
hostile right yeah I wouldn't say
hostile but I've been hearing about over
the last three months and it's just
as I was saying hostile
it's on the edge man yeah dude there's a
reason I smoke
have you picked aside yet on the uh
issues act you know I took I'm taking a
step back and I'm gonna go into
open-minded so uh thank you Zach so yeah
she worked Olivia worked hard on it so
thank you thank you very much I just got
a really cool text from Howie Mandel
who's just the greatest Howie Mandel
America's Uncle America's Uncle
America's Uncle Howie Mandel he's just
the man is just too much he's just too
much he's just amazing
are you saying I love you Howie I'm live
right now and I'm typing I'm live and
I'm typing and dictating
this text right now I'm fine people
right now to say I love you oh
that's true it's true
he could be my dad [__] it sorry Dad
what an art new dad what an arc remember
when he reached out and he wanted to
have you on the show and you're like how
are you Mandel I don't know and I was
like listen it's America's Uncle you're
gonna it has been a crazy Arc actually
I'm so glad it all worked out you know
and he's just I can't say enough nice
things about him like he's such a good
sport
he came over here he stared at into a
man doing a prolapse alive and he still
wants to be my friend
number one podcast in the world it's
beautiful
he might be the greatest guy I've ever
known he's inspiring me to be a better
person
is he really kind of yeah because he's
so
[Music]
the way that he just goes through life
he's got the best disposition he he's so
amicable you know he takes everything in
stride we put him through a lot we did
do not want to get canceled and here he
is just touching my heart he was very
kind when I saw him uh in public oh yeah
very welcoming great dude
he's just the best you know
uh we actually have an album as of his
fits
that we're not sure oh yeah because we
were saying he's a fashion icon when he
was rocking the teddy fresh well
he's always been a fashion icon here he
is in the fireman shape
which I'm not even gonna lie looks
pretty fire
like Ian you that's kind of a dope
outfit right because I asked because
you're like kind of streetwear what
yeah you're kind of sure you're kind of
yeah you're a hypey super dope Ian's
cool as [__] what I can't ask any
questions now no of course everything's
got to be like oh yeah sure it's just me
Ian you wear streetwear
Sam's Sam's more of the fashionista out
of the two of us I'd say but I
appreciate the support yeah yeah it's
looking good
Sam do you what do you think since
you're you got the nod I think it's
great I'm just wondering he's got to be
burning up yeah yeah I'm all about like
practical like I think it looks really
cool but it's not the weather for that
he's burning up
fire
well I'll tell you he I think he just
does the catwalk
like from the car to the studio and then
it comes off right
oh
the ramen soup what happened about that
back there he's very proud of that I'm
very happy with that this one's out in
public I don't even know that oh maybe
this one is oh uh quick um update your
mother uh Donna Klein just send me a
message
um saying she likes Howie Mandel but
don't diss dad [__] she heard that you
heard that Deez Nuts
sorry I didn't know you guys would be
listening
I hope I do her proud today sorry Dad
remember she called in
oh true she's all she's all hip to the
Selena
yeah so this is pretty cool what is this
he's so hip dude
such a hip ass dude it's so cool he is
so cool that's how I feel
subscribe we've done we've done the
rounds here
you all know I think 90 of his Subs must
be H3 podcast listeners
uh this I guess was during the height of
kovid you can't be too safe
I pooped today that's good to announce I
think that's important
he looks great too and he's in shape he
looks great man
fantastic
I came I saw I made it awkward
no you he hasn't made anything awkward
stop it
so that's Howie he'll be my uncle I
guess not my friend
could get over for a Passover seder
tonight his place you know we had our
Passover on the weekend just because
um
I know everyone's busy so like we'll
just do it on Sunday it was fun
so what's happening backstage there's
you're glitching a little bit the main
shot oh I'm glitching The Matrix
the audio is okay though yeah okay
Dan is uh fidgeting with the camera
we're doing an unplug a re-plug
and now we are looking sharp and good to
go
yeah I want to give us a quick reminder
we all have been uh talking about the
Godzilla drop that's coming out it's
coming out tomorrow
[Applause]
uh at 10 A.M PST
get it while it's hot
oh well it's not out I don't know why
I'm showing you the website it's not oh
yeah but I showed you all the Styles uh
they're freaking cool as hell this shirt
[Music]
you still got it oh I still got it boy
don't call it a comeback
been here for years oh here's a little
post about it this one doesn't really
show all the stuff I feel like our
fashion show showed a lot of the good
stuff but this is Sam's set that she
made which is definitely super perfect
thank you
yeah
I know I'm such a zilla head dude I'm
just I'm thrilled with this one a Toto
head isn't that the name that's the
studio yeah well they own it they own
the IPA right yeah yeah yeah
they're one of the only collabs we've
done where we actually work with
like We're working directly with them
it's interesting with Godzilla himself
they're really good people man telling
you
so let's do some top of the show stuff
and then we'll get into the big Bonanza
um
y'all really want to debate what xqc
said the carrot guy
you guys all know the carrot guy xqc the
gambling guy whatever I guess he's
friends now because you guys took photos
of him the juice man now you all really
just want to be friends with him because
you met him and he was nice you're ready
to leave me for xqc I've been a fan
since day one dude
yeah I know I know you're a juicer
I won't make you pick between us I
didn't meet him so you and I can still
hate on him thank you yeah he can go
[__] himself thank you oh yeah Zach
either yeah
that's just mean
is that anything wrong with okay I feel
like I I can decode this really I'm lost
in there she had the building
constructive but just there's nothing
wrong okay hold on is that anything
wrong with him she had the building
constructive but just there's nothing
wrong with accepting accountability and
being constructive
there's nothing wrong with streamers is
there anything wrong with streamers
I mean it is interesting way to stop
don't get me wrong
turning across that just mean
yeah
that's just mean well I heard that's
just mean right yeah yeah I hear that
all right hold on is that anything wrong
with Jim is right in there there's
nothing wrong with streamers we all on
the page nothing wrong with streamers
you're you're not even gonna meet me
there Dan no no I'm just concentrating
I'm like really trying I'm blocking out
making acceptability something
constructive but just and being
constructive representing communities
were turning across that's just me
something about Jesus died on a cross
yeah I think you know that is just me
that's just me it is it was just me and
what they did to Jesus yeah
well love you're the xqc uh historian
sure but like his language is cons uh
contextual like when you when you see
the whole context you understand what he
says he's cutting out a little section
like this it's hard
earlier okay well we should say he's a
he's a French speaker so this is a
second language and I can't talk [__]
so anyone who speaks two languages is
cool in my book is that anything except
the building constructive but just a
white within the community people always
returning across that just mean that's
great that's such a wild uh he's saying
the web attend Community or something
like that web 10.
I thought we were on web3 yeah
who skipped over a whole seven
website the building constructed any
communities across that just mean he
lost me on the second part I got no idea
there's nothing wrong with a streamer's
chat giving construct being constructive
that's the first part okay okay
let me see did he say chat is that
anything wrong with Jim is writing there
she had the building constructed but
just to watch chat and then like rolling
over the word
that's what I thought I was thinking
Community across that's just mean I just
hear Jesus was on a cross and that was
just me there's something wrong with the
streamers taking accountability and
giving them constructive criticism but
now them to a cross is just mean oh he
actually said nailing them to a cross oh
nailing them to a cross are you really
trying to do like this man is barely
literate and he's trying to drop like
metaphors on me about nailing people
maybe you're wrong about that maybe he's
secretly a genius and it's just hidden
he's smart he's a smart guy
emotional oh he's reading a shot
did you now baby is that your
translation or did you actually get that
is that a definite that is from actually
from chat I was reading Chad's guesses
but that one was the best okay you seem
right
across that's just me I don't hear the
nailing them to a cross I don't hear
that hold on hold on building
constructive but just to wipe any
Community across that's just mean I
don't hear that I don't hear that it's
just
someone in chat said but the ones I've
come across are just mean okay that
seems more like what he's saying hold on
let me go back now
but just to fight with any communities
with turning across that's just I don't
know it's not there there's it's not I
don't know that he said anything he's
reading a donation
um so he's not saying this or uh he's
reading it I'm just reading it he
doesn't even know what he's saying yeah
you know if twitch doesn't work out for
him he'd be a great Auctioneer auction
area could have been a one now too today
uh horse races
right
but just to watch any Community always
will turn it across that's just mean
is that anything wrong with it all right
well there it is xqc everybody America's
favorite streamer
Community across that just mean someone
uh the poster said finally someone had
to say it oh wait wait oh W Community I
think I found a description on the
original tweet go ahead is there
anything wrong with streamers trying to
build something constructive but just to
wipe their community's piece of art
between a cross that's just mean okay
that was way off but that's right but
that's not none of us heard that what
does it mean to wipe the community's
piece of art between a cross wiping is
optional what does that mean between a
cross
between a cross
hold on let me is that anything wrong
with sermons right in there she had the
building constructive but just to watch
any Community always was turning across
that's just me that doesn't make sense
thank you uh thank you that makes sense
I could watch this all day frankly but
we have plenty of others to get to
um that just mean it is just mean well
said we're Arab world news uh friends of
the show and heart of the show frankly
this man is posting
he's gonna make me cry man y'all
remember Arab world news of course the
delivering the hardest hitting news
um Arab water news family oh he renamed
his channel it's awesome
you got that inspiring message for a b
let me see if you've got any interesting
news stories lately that we can watch
before reading this
let's see look lots of sports news yeah
he's into uh Sports which is great we
love that for him
but here's what he said
being a member of H3 family expect
anything
you want to know the size of H3 family
look at the sky and count the Stars
if you want to know how much love you
will get count the raindrops wow and if
you want to know when this love will
stop stand on the seashore and wait for
the waves to end
that's actually beautiful man wow
I wish that
we could get this message out to some of
the alpha Bros
[Music]
yeah those are gay bro
s okay [__] Bay Street family is like
the winter sun spreading warmth after
cold nights
the H3 family is like a huge Rock
huge [__] sorry wait what does it say
this is Rock a rock HP family is like a
huge Rock
over which any restrictions are
shattered so that it gives the
opportunity for beginners to succeed and
for the successful to succeed even more
beautiful the H3 family is the Moonlight
when the power goes out lighting the way
for the fair the Wayfarers and the lost
Drifters
hmm
I was one of those once
before I found this family you know it
really does sound like this
the history family is like a tree that
gives fruit to anyone in need and when
its fruits run out it Still Remains
beautiful and whole
the H3 family broke barriers borders and
distances that's Gathering foot soldiers
on peace and love
if there are aliens they will join this
family to raise your head up to the sky
and say at the top of your voice family
family family family family
family
from family
that is moving man
holy [__] dude I love this man he is
such a sweetheart such a tender Soul
such a nice guy
really tearing down the borders of the
world
I don't see borders anymore all I see is
family
family Without Borders
okay this one's from 18 hours ago it's
about soccer but football whatever
I should see I don't want to get claimed
so let's just cut to the chase here
oh he's not even in it okay
um well and
I feel this not every not everything
needs commentary he might have been
commenting over it like just with audio
you think so let's try let's see
[Music]
good good good you're right
equalizing penalty to cancel our example
Stadium
[Music]
it
sounded kind of generic but we don't
know we just don't know
um one thing that we do know is I saw
several people in the chat claiming uh
he may have used
um uh AI to help write that okay
I'm sorry to say but that was 100 from
the human heart baby
it's the real deal how dare you question
our world news yeah so shout out to um
Arab world news whose family forever man
we all look at the same Stars we all
look at the same sky today I
feel Arab frankly
facts
not anymore moving on no I'm just
kidding
um thank you Mary Jane uh getting
married in 30 minutes dude get off the
[__] computer
thanks for being a part of so many
laughs we've shared over the years oh
well that's nice thank you but go being
married Jesus Christ man
I want you to watch as much as possible
but you know there's exceptions
you know you should be like to the
pastor or whatever yeah hold on one sec
this is good
hold that hold on they're talking about
snico I really want to hear this oh [__]
I've been waiting for them yeah he's
this guy he he got cucked by his
girlfriend is crazy uh you I'll tell you
afterwards to the priest or something
yeah we've been talking a lot about
Fallen fans and I've dubbed a new term
Born Again fans
because there's fans that have left and
they've come back and this is a whole
scientific field I feel like we as
family need to excavate and understand
as much as possible here is
here is the account of a born-again fan
uh
uh I went through a long phase of just
really not enjoying listening to Ethan's
podcast
you know
before Frenemies I would say we were
going through a severe drought of
repetitiveness not really being inspired
and as I said I was depressed I wasn't
super into the show I was struggling
with how to do it
and I feel that even after Frenemies
ended this show has really stepped up
into something that is special and a
much better product so I totally
understand that
now I watch every show come on and I'm
not an alpha or a conservative but I
have definitely called myself a fallen
fan
the thing that changed for me was that
Ethan created a larger podcast Community
by bringing in Dan Ian Abe and more
importantly the female voices Sam Olivia
and Lena shout out I agree you know
bringing on the cast creates a much more
Dynamic experience with uh diversity
that's part of what in my opinion what
made the show so much better is um
having this kind of community in here
and all these people to care about and
all everyone's so funny and creative and
interesting
um
and that's one thing I really borrowed
from Howard Stern you know is I can't
imagine doing it by myself now this show
is so [__] boring and awkward
you know
thought the laughter
Sharon says I've been born again thank
you Wham Ethan Wham watch Olivia Wilde
wove weiner wheeler
you guys names is like almost the same I
just realized
you guys are just one letter difference
kind of interesting something to think
about
does it mean something
it's fascinating it's very fascinating
yeah you know as as a big fan of Howard
Stern his he always has all these great
crew
segments and they were some of my
favorite bits that they ever did so
I'm happy that we created this kind of
space here too and I thank all you guys
too for you know doing so good
just made the show more of a back and
forth and made it so Ethan sometimes
overly negative hey negative takes and
spirals get controlled
uh Zach's sound bites also made it worth
keeping up and by adding lore keeping
the show fun online absolutely Zach
thank you absolutely thank you very much
I can't stress stress enough that the
podcast is made great because of the
crew and the dynamic they all share I
think a lot of people left during the
time when Ethan was still figuring
things out his mood really uh translated
into what I found to be an overly
negative and critical show at times
that's fair yeah
that's fair I would definitely spiral at
times oh for sure man you look back at
some of those
boy it got real dark in that in there
sometimes man during some of our brutal
cancellations and then we get super
defensive it was bad times there
I think it's important to realize that
your Fallen fans are not all
conservative Jim Bros okay
We Like Jordan Peterson many people who
don't like Ethan are incredible people
with values that are identical to
Ethan's okay so I always thought that
people didn't like these shows were that
didn't like my show were demons and they
must just be Freaks and demons and
outcasts and losers but it turns out
there are good people that don't watch
this show
and that's worth bearing in mind I think
the Pod is doing a great job to cross
the veil again and opening the floor to
people once again uh they once deemed
disgusting horrible like Bryce Jeff Mike
Dana I genuinely think that it can be
something really special in the show
people can get over their differences
and change for better but Ethan needs to
[__] unplug the toilet first what the
[__] dude okay I the toilet is unclogged
I please
I can't go down that
Plumbing hole again
yeah you know um
the dead air got so long I just had to
let it keep going
actually I'm not I wanted to keep see
how long I could keep it going
um
you know like Howard Stern again I bring
him up because he has such a great radio
show that inspired me he's been on the
radio for like 40 50 [__] years
long time and so I totally agree that
we're just figuring this out it's crazy
that we went from
having zero broadcast experience
to being Fully live doing a podcast so
there was a lot for us to learn a lot
for us to adjust to a lot of team
building and gear building and system
building
that we've been doing over the past God
six years almost six years it's been
and I feel like uh
you know these things take a lot of time
to get good at so and I feel this I feel
this so thank you to the born-again fans
who giving us another
yeah Chad is saying Ela and Lena are not
one letter different I know that but
it's like if you just change
right it doesn't work that way at all
you know Ian and I's names are one
letter different as Are Cam and Sam's
there's lots of examples
picked one what does it mean
what does it mean
there's no such thing as a coincidence
what does that mean
hmm
and crunch the numbers on that what are
the odds
yeah but uh thank you to the born-again
fans I do really want to be receptive
and open so that we can grow the show uh
and you know it feels good when there's
people watching and you're not in minus
20 000 Subs all the time I'll tell you
good looking at the the dashboard we're
at negative two thousand Maybe
yeah let's go yeah and if this is your
first time watching the show today feel
free to hit that subscribe button okay
first time fan if you're a born-again
fan you know whatever it may be if
you're just a long time fan you realize
you were subscribed hit that subscribe
button for us you never know what will
happen that's that like button turn the
Bell notifications on that's right so
we've got the Fallen fans they're demons
they're demonic we have the Born Again
fans who found Jesus again so what do
you call the ones who are just being
baptized for the first time
like the ones who just got here and like
oh I like this show
uh newborns baptize the newborn so born
okay newborn and born again right born
again yeah because I was thinking
baptism or something that's when you
become a Christian right when you get
baptized or you become saved uh right
yeah I mean different kind of baptism
they do it at different times depending
on the uh someone saved me whatever
anyway thank you guys for uh for all
that appreciate that
we got some fun little Goofs here
man I open one of these things you guys
ever open one of these air compressed
foam mattresses
uh yeah I got one of those once and it
is very frightening it's actually very
impressive
let's see lady you're underestimating
that thing
that was faster than mine open where did
you go it's so cartoon-like
is that the Acme uh yeah it's very
actress
she just disappeared
what the
thinks she might be uh Gravely injured
there but the mattress wins finally
tired of getting sat on all the time you
know
uh Dave pork boy enemy of the show
actually got dissed on by attack on
Twitter that was pretty fun there's a
whole uh narrative going on behind the
scenes with sports uh women's basketball
now I saw this clip going around
on social media
of this player uh
Angel Reese
and I guess she's a big deal in the in
the game
probably
and uh she was showboating a little bit
and people I saw on the internet were
angry at her in fact Dave porkboy called
her a classless piece of [__] dude like
people are so soft what you can't you
can't talk [__] oh boy [__] of all
people yeah exactly man coming for a
young girl
they're like what the [__] my friends
have been doing that since we were kids
playing basketball how soft are you what
does it mean something about the ring
we're probably all wrong but back home
they just do it because John Cena like
you can't see me I'm too fast oh I think
she's pointing to a ring oh she's not
the winner yeah that that was my
impression as well maybe it's the fast
thing
she did that as well she was all fast
ring whatever it's all he hear
well here it is here's the disc that uh
prompted poor Dave pork boy to have this
such a horrible sad reaction in Angel
Reese
goes a ring is coming and this light got
70 000 likes so he was
also Loki that's classless as hell to
post something like that
right well and Dave Dave a paragon of
class he's like [__] no dude this is the
man who did an interview she's like do
you really think it's appropriate to
make jokes about like uh r word he's
like apparently I do apparently I do
think it's funny which is fine but like
why are you being so sensitive now Shaq
actually came back
and said and so is your mother
[Music]
sure
actually there is a little backstory
here too because
um
the thing is there are screenshots of
Clark the girl who she's doing it to
here
okay who was doing the exact same thing
to her
and she was just responding at first
right she did it first so she was
talking [__] except when the white girl
did it Dave pork boy didn't have no no
problem this isn't that [__]
interesting so she was literally just
responding to this other girl talking
[__] here she is
right
and she's like okay
we can we can both tangle and don't you
think it's just a little [__] up that
she does it first and then she responds
and then Dave porkboy is the one on here
going classless piece of [__] that's
nuts that's like such a self-report
[__] ass I knew I didn't like him
douche
he posted an edit of it
but they did the same thing are you
really trying to defend yourself right
now
this man's I just watched them do the
exact same thing I don't know what he's
saying okay so he he's trying to defend
himself but they did the same thing
bread Dade he said brain dead people
think they did the same thing again 50
000 likes so
he's got all the uh
The Classy people online so interesting
Super Chat from uh from one of the rare
uh the [__] Barstool slash uh H3 fans
saying with peace and love uh it's his
stick to go after the other team when he
loses a big bet it was a joke with peace
and love oh I don't
why is he defending himself that's what
I was about to say is uh I mean if it's
a joke it's kind of weird to double down
right yeah I want to double down if it
was like just a joke because it's really
[__] up and also a lot of people are
agreeing with him it's not like ah right
just goofing around here she sucks I
hate her right I guess now he's just
having a big joke out of it also Shaq
who knows a lot more about sports than
me especially basketball seems to uh
comment on him that's like the Sebastian
Angel where he says oh I'm just kidding
online but you're like making all these
young men uh think the way you think
right is that plausible deniability it's
like no
it's you you thinking that way it's not
the issue you making other people think
that way is the issue There It Is Love
[__]
[__] she idiot dumbass
but they're doing the same thing am I
[__] out of my mind what is he [__]
is he is this a joke maybe this is a
joke I mean if he's just purely trolling
so be it but it's like one of those
things where it's like this is the one
on the right slo-mo too
I see what's going on here oh then
there's more okay there's more that's
where it ended so it's not a joke that's
where it ended
and then now she's following her and
doing it who cares bro you never seen
smack talk in sports the biggest [__]
talker of them all too I'm surprised
he's got an issue with this I thought
people liked when athletes were like
spunky like that it's fun they do like
Kobe's like a legend Kobe Bryant's like
a legendary smack talker Michael Jordan
I think was too
[__] dumbass
loser dumbass sorry I don't think it's a
joke man this guy really is going a long
way to defend himself
get a life dummy you guys think it's a
joke uh so before we move on uh the chat
is complaining that the crackling audio
issue we were having the other week just
started to come back uh-oh
um so let me uh let's see if there's
anything I can do about it
[Music]
started when I started talking might be
my mind did you curse it did you curse
us love maybe here let me what the frick
let me listen to it what the freak
well hit me with the elevator music as a
while we wait
we're having some technical difficulties
here at the H3 podcast Studios
a little bit of a crackling sound you
guys might notice here
uh it might be just Bruce yelling
Percy
okay so based off the reaction from the
chat I thought our audio was completely
taking a [__] um there's a slight issue
um
I don't know if it's worth uh stopping
the stream and restarting for it or if
we should just move on uh we can take a
poll it seems like enough people are
bothered by it I mean people are
bothered by it clearly I don't think
let's do a poll I mean it seems like a
lot of people are
not loving the snap crackle pop
uh we don't have to do a poll why don't
we just do it then like
it's very mild it's not that bad
hear that for a podcast dude yeah
exactly so why don't we just see you but
you think resetting it's going to fix it
uh I don't know that for sure there's
only one way to know but there's all
right guys please come back everybody
please come back do not do this to me uh
the stream won't actually it'll just
buffer for like a second okay here we'll
be right back thank you
[Music]
foreign
okay I just uh stopped and started it
theoretically we should be back we are
back welcome back everybody
April 5th oh because we're on a delay I
didn't see until now that now all of the
chat is just it's not a big deal
whatever just move on don't reset it
it's not that bad where were all of you
people 10 seconds ago well I prefer be
gone
you don't want any yeah no I I prefer
it's gone too but yeah boys did I miss
the sun everyone's gone now
we're all back here hopefully it's
better now
people can't see the streams though
that's the button for you
uh
I'm waiting for people to acknowledge
that we're back in China we're back
we're 100 back oh they're saying better
there you go okay sometimes just turn it
off and on again
I'll be back Sharon says Ian Slater is a
king that's all
thoughts in
I appreciate that thank you
so true I agree and he appreciates that
was that a recording or was that wait
did you actually thank her at all Ian
I
appreciate that thank you that one
sounded great appreciate that thank you
okay wait now I'm confused
stupid
this is all a sound bite I'm not
actually talking
okay now I'm really confused
Ian just put it on you so I can tell
when you're thought this is all a sound
bite I'm not actually talking now put
put the camera on you because I can't I
appreciate that thank you switch the
camera to you dude yeah I I haven't yeah
I had lunch
I like legs and uh
ass I like legs and uh ass nailed that
one hey do you need to go to the
bathroom
I got a piece so bad he's really got any
action down I gotta pee so bad
I wish I could just stay in and then I'd
know for sure
what was going on back there I
appreciate that thank you
oh here we go
[Laughter]
Ian you need to go to the bathroom
Dan can uh sit for you
Dan you want to fill in for Ian while he
goes to the bathroom absolutely
[Music]
I got him so bad
that's a dirty ass dubstep
is that dubstep
that is elements of drug stuff in there
it's complicated what do you call it
like Neo grunge step uh Exodus
all right thank you Ian uh we love you
very good
uh we got some David dobrik the there's
a name I haven't heard in a minute some
weird David dobrik for shattering from
his hot ones
cameo
David dobrik said in 2020 interview
before the excavator accident there's no
such thing as a accident team Jeff like
recurring nightmares ever there are only
like themes are there anything is there
anything that recurs I used to have one
where I was in the backseat of my car
and I would take my eyeball out and I
would put it in the cup holder and I
used to have that one a lot
I don't have that one anymore
he's obsessed with eyes and now he's
claimed three of them and you know what
he put keeps him in the [__] cup
holder
for that
he never has to take his own eye out the
man he has a fetish for eyeballs or
something what am I forgetting what is
the third what am I forgetting childhood
friend I remember that Jeff yeah and and
wasn't there a third
there's a sculpture
I thought there was a third eye incident
I feel like there was I just don't
remember what it was yeah there was a
third eye we're like dude this man has
taken three eyeballs now hmm Three's a
pattern
three is definitely a pattern
yeah I remember he had like an eyeball
sculpture like commissioned which was
pretty wild but I'm trying to think what
the uh
the third incident was
uh oh dirty Dom says he's coming for me
oh no wait
and Chris Hans Chris Hansen is
investigating me
says dirty Dom he's just desperate for
me to watch but that's fine again nice
to meet you again
bro has the worst haircut
can I say that
absolutely that haircut is crazy dumb
you can say whatever he looks like a
dumb cartoon character like the idiot
cartoon character with the dumb haircut
it's like forwarded spiky get your [__]
together bro
uh he hit Natalie in the eye is what
we're thinking of okay for the third
okay he hitting that oh yeah yeah yeah
yes there was an accident they he filmed
it on Tick Tock there was like the fire
thing
something he did hit her in the eye and
she was bleeding
okay he tried to take Natalie's eye that
does sound Vaguely Familiar all right
let's see what the [__] this idiot has
to say what happened to H3 yeah we're
working on something me and Chris Hanson
are working on something well he's he's
kidding obviously no this isn't the
first time he said it Rubble lamp okay
he's got own [__]
he just said rub a lamp y'all
say that that's the meme from I remember
but why did he say because they're
spamming it oh yeah chat okay got it got
it got it rub a lamp dummy take down H3
wait is that from the members or was
that
that was for Monday that was Monday yeah
that was Monday I get confused sometimes
when I tell you what bye okay
um
look at the comments H3 absorbed another
hairline I see so I'll just get off the
internet
just go move to like
Arizona and do construction or something
man just start a new life anyone here
from Arizona
it's awesome dude
family
what does that mean like a genie
uh lots of penguin I'm trash Airline as
you as you can see he really got me good
there brothers and sisters that's right
rub a lamp there brother I'll tell you
what Rubble lamp and wish for your
career to come back because you're
[__] never coming back dude
especially not with that haircut you
paid someone for that
you think he paid someone for that 10.
um you might have done self I hope so
possible
that's a crazy cut dude
it's everywhere
but hair is really fanned out at the top
yeah that's what I'm saying it's all
over the place
all right well Dom
you are a giant loser and I have no
interest in having you on the podcast he
keeps going why won't Ethan have me on
the podcast to debate like debate what
dummy
there's no debate he's nuts
exactly got him
idiot Rebel lamp idiot
dumbass
uh
wuji donated said my name Jeff
thank you Jeff
that is your real name
everybody's bitching about the audio
again as of oh [__] why is it doing that
I don't know
damn I don't know
here is the video of of David trying to
take Natalie's eye out
yeah in case you guys have to work for
free for a week
dude he's so weird
why did he do that
why did he
purr
I didn't like but he did that give me a
bad vibe
am I the only one it's just really bad
vibes that sound
if I make this you guys have to work for
free for a week
[Music]
can you grab that Zach sure
you can't see the new Spider-Man movie
the day it comes out oh
right he's just slapped her in the
[__] face like super hard
I didn't get where's the joke on this
one I forgot a violent that kind of is
so violent yeah
he's so [__] crazy funny he's so
crazy and then he uploaded that [__]
oh my god dude I'm gonna see I'm gonna
see dobrik on an episode of Dateline I'm
sure of it
it's a little old timey
hey woman
when did I say you could speak
oh time you like that
not even a single question for how are
you are you okay he's laughing harder
than anyone go she's bleeding
blood boiling dude they're crazy they're
all so nuts
I love me imagine I slapped one of you
in the face so hard you bled and laughed
at you and then put it online
that's that's their boss
work with me
yeah
moving on here we got uh
Linus Tech tip this is pretty funny
he's making a stunning admission here a
fellow YouTuber Linus Tech tip good guy
nice guy
talented guy
um he admits to using the hard r
that's crazy thing to admit but I guess
it's good to be honest
I mean it's been it's been kind of uh
it's been kind of eye-opening I I've
sort of randomly here and there picked
up episodes of you know old shows that I
hadn't watched in a long time from like
the early 2000s and just the Casual
um The Casual sort of gay humor casual
use of the hard R
um oh really it's jarring yeah it's it's
jarring now and for casual use of hard
art yeah
yeah absolutely like uh like okay it was
an episode of American Dad and it was
just like yeah it wasn't for shock value
it was just
just like used right well I mean here's
the thing right
that was in the 2003 or something like
2002. yeah like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna deny that I dropped my fair share
of hard hours back then because we
didn't even think I didn't even exist
this guy is like what is happening right
now holy [__] he's like delete me from
this conversation
dude that reaction was [__] awesome I
that I dropped my fair share of hard
hours back then because we didn't even
know the term hard
right and it's funny because to me that
right it doesn't feel and that long ago
but to my kids am I talking like n-word
harder what no okay I'm pretty sure
that's how people use that term no I
think so n word
what are you guys talking about
what is he talking about am I mistaken I
think so
dude no the one the one with the uh like
for like mental disability I'm pretty
sure people use hard what wait what
actually what a sweetheart
oh my God this is one of the greatest
Clips on the internet oh God
I've never heard a restarted referred to
the hard R because you don't really hit
it with a hard R restarted
but he's such a sweet guy he didn't even
think about what he was saying in a very
different way than you just used it
oh
okay either means ending I understand I
understand I understand what you mean no
I'm not talking about that okay cool so
um
over here dude we're dodging bullets
that's bad that was really bad oh my God
that was so [__] good this reaction
was everything to me one two yeah like
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna deny that I
dropped my fair share of hard hours back
then because we didn't even the term
hard art didn't even exist
[Music]
right now
oh that's funny good man he's a good man
he's a he's a sweet guy man
he's too wholesome to know
there you go
yes I've dropped my fair share of
I never dropped to any fair share of
nothing on nobody
got him what was that David
[Music]
have you dropped a hard R before
be honest with me you can be honest
[Music]
okay all right missed the mark with that
one all right
[Music]
he sounds like those door stoppers you
know when you go Bing and it goes
[Music]
idiot dumbass
yeah
good stuff
Harry Potter reboot is in the mix I
wanted to get your guys's thoughts on
this
um HBO is apparently in talks to do a
Harry Potter reboot
each season is going to be one of seven
books so seven seasons in total this is
very interesting obviously we don't like
uh
jk Are a raffling lame-o but I do love
Harry Potter JK Rowling I like JK
rofling she sucks yeah I'm not giving
her respect I think you threw an RR in
there like George as well
JK Rowling more like
rolling
more like stop dropping rolling because
you're
careers on uh she's cute okay
[Applause]
she's really uh very successful yeah
what do you guys think I hate to admit
that I would watch this I hate it
I would you would watch it I would I
would have would why because I [__]
because Harry Potter is awesome it's
magic bro wands carrots I like it dude I
would I would watch that [__] you know
in a robe and a hat and a wand I can't
dude I love it I love the rides I love
the movies I love the magic okay I read
the books hater asked Dan I am I know
you all hate JK Rowling I don't like her
but like I can't just ignore the biggest
franchise in the world you know what I
mean but you know you know the story You
Know How It Ends you know how it plays
out what you guys won't watch it since
I'm not watching this [__] it's cool
since when did knowing the story prevent
you from watching when you've already
seen it also why do we need we just did
it yeah I just did it no we just did
Harry Potter the movies you know how old
that shit's old as hell the last movie
came out less than 10 years ago
what when did the last movie come out
what was the last one called uh Deathly
Hallows part two Deathly Hallows part
two
uh 2011. okay so it was over 10 years
ago and all right when did the first one
come out dude because that [__] was
ancient yeah yeah I was like a child 97
90s 99. Daniel was it really that no
okay
98 Daniel no no no it was 2001. what
yeah yeah it was 2001. and uh 91
Worcester Stone 2001 2001. it was one
the first movie the book came out God
damn 20 yeah 22 years ago Dude
yeah I kind of like if it was just a
different series not The the movies yeah
dude there's a big universe make some
more wizard [__] yeah no I want exactly
better wizard [__] because every time
they knew make new Wizard [__] it sucks
sucks all the new Wizard [__] inaccurate
the [__] the story is awesome I want
to relive the magic go watch the go
watch the d d movie that just came out
it's got wizard [__] almost way cooler
wizard I'll watch it's a movie though
I'll watch a movie I don't know I love
wizard [__] dude I have time to watch
both my nickname is Dan the wizard I
know wizard [__] all right
I know a thing or two about wizard [__]
also like we get to watch it where
Dumbledore doesn't mysteriously like
change into a totally different actor
for no reason
I'll speak too soon
yeah I mean there's still time for
reasons let's do a poll are you gonna
watch this I know all you are going to
watch it because it's gonna be dub it's
gonna be super high budget it's gonna be
awesome and then everyone's gonna be
like yo this movie rules Harry Potter
HBO has been making some great [__] hbo2
is the fact that HBO is making it is
what's so hype because they don't [__]
around with series like that
if it was like Netflix
or Hulu or Amazon I'd be like I don't
know about all that but the fact that
it's HBO you guys it's HBO oh wow the
nose are in the lead okay haters [__]
let's just remove the fact that JK
Rowling's like a giant piece of [__]
from the equation if that's possible
I know y'all still listen to Michael
Jackson don't [__] lie to me I mean
that that in my case is irrelevant
because I didn't was never into the
Harry Potter thing so you know it wasn't
JK that turned me on wait the yeses are
coming back ignore JK Rowling's a piece
of [__] ignore that put that aside for
now
even still I'd want new Wizard [__] well
the new Wizard [__] sucks bro you've
seen the wonderful world of crazy
Critters or whatever
I want new Wizard [__] dude it doesn't
even have to be Harry Potter specific I
just want different wizard [__] yeah
let's write a book then write a wizard
book cam come on it's not let me get
chat to do it for me yeah exactly huh
your hair look your facial hair looks
good Kim let me see cam you look
handsome today thank you so do you we're
it's the mustache dude you actually it
suits you wait let me see cam
I like the the stubble and the mustache
look is very nice on you I think that is
better than them they look great cam is
my favorite
dude the community is torn on this man
51 yes
wow I'm disappointed
I want the same story I want the magic
new Wizard [__]
what do you think AB you're a Harry
Potter boy aren't you yeah I know I love
her you [__] with this right yeah
obviously I don't support JK Rowling she
sucks yeah it's it's terrible because
when I was a kid it was like all the
outcasts Who Loved Harry Potter and
that's why he's so [__] up what she
did because her Main
fan base I feel like was the
the outcast the unusual ones she
probably had a lot of lgbtq people who
were [__] with it yeah and
identifying with the Journey of the
characters yeah and she's like nah not
not you guys
this book's not for you guys
the only thing is that I don't think
anyone could replace uh Alec Rickman
Snape Alan Rickman oh God yeah I was but
you know what you'd be surprised I'm not
looking to replace him yeah but I feel
like man I just I hope that there's not
like little kids I can't do that again I
don't want like a little like
eight-year-old playing Harry that's the
no I want like story no he's a child
nope
I want like that thing where they have
like 20 year olds who play like uh play
children play like middle schoolers yeah
yeah
[__] but the nose have it that's
surprising me I'm sorry babe okay we
have demons in the chat 666 from a b
that babies
shut demon you see that you have a simp
in the donations baby a b Abe the babest
oh it's not about you sorry bro it's
about Abe it's okay
Abe it's about Abe the babest
[Applause]
bro he's 11. Harry's 11. okay so then
get an 18 year old
I want somebody to connect
and you know what
I'm actually since it's HBO
now that I'm thinking more about it it
could be kind of good like if they
just kind of went like a Euphoria uh
sort of method with it I mean it is like
it's it's a High School drama in a way
it's like maybe like a lot of sex they
started drinking some funny potions
started having some Visions right making
a joke you're making a big joke of all
this
yeah
what goes on in the uh Chamber of
Secrets my friend
before we find out what goes on in that
chamber Zach just watched it recently
for the first time right I am a new
Harry Potter fan oh yeah oh come on oh
yeah yeah India dude Zach's having a
whole Renaissance he's doing Legos he's
watching Harry Potter oh man I'm deep in
Legos baby we got him into Lord of the
Rings just recently too you know yeah oh
that's exciting for you yeah Ian Ian
showed me the light you mean reading or
watching watching and I never saw the
series
what the the original movies the three
movies no I know I never saw them oh my
god did you watch them all [__] yeah did
you love the greatest things I've ever
seen isn't that crazy and then I watched
the um the extended Cuts those are great
yeah
um it's like 11 hours yeah I don't like
tree man though that's my only criticism
how come you don't like the tree man I
just found it boring I don't know
they're so cool in the book I feel like
they weren't as cool in the movie I you
know I love those movies when he said
that I had to acknowledge I that is
probably the most boring part of the
entire Trilogy is the hobbits with the
with Treebeard and I like the the
transfer cool like the giant talking
trees that [__] up a bunch of Orcs like
that's awesome but if so born
by the way we got a number two my name
Jeff number two from woo Jack thank you
Jeff oh a lot of jets in the chat here
today I'm watching Lord of the Rings for
the first time whoa right and I cannot
believe Ian got me to watch it
because they're so long and I'm not even
watching the extended one
they're way too long the first one I
love the first one I am struggling to
get through the second one right now wow
okay all right all right different stuff
like four nights this is Sam who by the
way no offense because I watch it too
we'll sit through the three hour
Bachelor finale
because that's real [__]
that's true she's
right I don't know I I'm liking Lord of
the Rings but
I don't know I I'm such a movie hater in
general so I'm I feel that yeah I don't
know it's hard these days to just sit in
one [__] place movies are too long
one hour
we should cap movies at one hour
everything an hour and a half happened
in one hour
yeah but now these days I'll watch like
a dateline episode that's like three
hours long like no problem
they make that [__] long as hell I don't
know if anyone else [__] with those
shows we went and saw uh Dungeons and
Dragons in when we go Friday and I think
I slept through the last 45 minutes of
it in the theater that's my girl you
don't like High magic you don't like the
high fantasy it could be any movie I'm
gonna go to sleep that's like Sam's
thing is falling asleep in movies
I tried to pick a movie whatever you do
don't go see Schindler's List
I was like let me let me do a movie
where I there's no shot Sam will fall
asleep and I put on Mad Max Fury Road he
was out within 10 minutes oh my God it
didn't matter wow that's kind of a good
life hack if you need to sleep oh he's
[__] amazing
yes so um
the nose habit by the way on the Harry
Potter 53 days thank you I knew I I knew
I believed in you all for a reason yeah
it turns out in the HBO series Harry
Potter loses his virginity to the ghost
in the bathroom stall from the first one
yeah yeah Myrtle actually jerks them off
scene was very sexual well yeah the
ghost was into him the Goblet of Fire
when he's in the bathtub I don't know
just yeah they're actually calling it
the gobble the fire
change
thank you everybody I'll be here all
week literally every week it's my job
a little old timey joke for y'all huh
gotta keep it all the time chocolate
mocha you know different flavor all
different flavors yeah so Jimmy Lee
speaking of which he discovered that he
has a direct line of communication to me
via Instagram DMS oh no they made the
mistake of responding to him once there
oh brother and now I'm now you're [__]
there yeah you're you're [__] but I
like you Jimmy I don't want to keep him
on red because we have a relationship
you know but he's asked me now like 10
times when's the live show and always I
say you'll be the first to know you will
be the first to know it'll be sometime
in June the end of June
you'll be the first to know did he did
was this yesterday yesterday the day
before the day before that yeah he's
doing this yesterday he asked me about
five times even telling him the same
information that you're relaying to him
this is from yesterday at 9am he says
hey buddy
please let me know when you have a
definite date for the live show it takes
me a while to plan and line stuff up
which I get you know I appreciate I get
that and then later in that day again he
said any date yet
I said you'll be the first to know he
said thanks honey bunny
thanks honey bun okay because of our
thing we had that one thing where we
were
we had Rapport we were like thanks honey
bunny right baby well that's Buttercup I
think he's so interested because I'm
sure he wants the plan to shoot around
it like that's I'm sure his motive of it
I don't think he needs any motives bro
because of him to just be able to do
stick for people
he should he banned dude he's going to
be able to imagine he's got in his you
know
his Sizzle reel him performing to 1600
people yeah that'll land him a bunch of
spots on Newsmax that's
so true
they'd be like yo who is this guy
uh sneako's talking about me
of course Nico
so this is actually an older clip oh it
is yeah yeah I believe this is following
up uh you going on Bradley Martin's
podcast
oh okay I never okay yeah because I I
had some things to say about him to
Bradley
so I don't even know if it's worth
watching but he's just such an unhinged
lunatic
way to take the audio out so oh is that
it was that uh yeah there was music in
the back oh that's right misinformation
and election misinformation stop lying
I'm like [__] did I say that about him
I think you said that he got banned for
uh sexually harassing that that's a
YouTuber that's why he got banned and
that's what I said I don't know why he
seems to be contending that no I
actually got banned for uh for denying
Cove it's real
much better no he said wait no he's
saying I say that about him and he and
he he's saying I'm lying and saying I
said that about him
by the way this clip gots a bunch of
views on Tick Tock of course like you
just mentioned anything it's like these
guys do this they don't even show what I
said they can create any hypothetical
situation where I said any [__] thing
that they can imagine and everyone just
takes it for granted
I said he got banned for that
which I don't recall ever saying stop
lying to my phone also who gives a [__]
you believe that [__] it's like it's not
a badge of honor [__] name that's not
why I got bad
people [__] ing lie chat
reservation I got banned for sexually
harassing a girl and and pretending to
to rape her
get it right dude
by the way I didn't even say that so I
don't know what he's tripping about is
this sex trafficker too [__] bro what
the [__]
I'm really pissed off because he's doing
the same thing trying to pay Tate as a
bad person trying to save a decent
section he's trying he's literally
having a panic attack over his
entertainers
the same thing he's what
he's literally shaking he is he's
shaking he's triggered he's crying and
shaking and [__] and pissing
much like at the orgy
right right I was crying I was [__]
I was pissing a dude was licking my
balls
about me he's trying to paint me in a
battle he's trying to make me seem like
a violent misogynist
that's true I do think you are well I
don't know if you're yeah
yeah you are a violent misogynist Nico
does that all on his own that'll co-sign
just tell them why you did get banned
bro
that's how he got banned
I got banned for telling a girl I was
gonna r word her no he didn't do that
but pretty much yeah at least do your
research before you get on this platform
and talk about why you would assume that
I'm a sexual assaulter this is [__]
defamation bro sue me then idiot I think
I was right I think he I think he's
reacting to you saying all the stuff
about him being a violent misogynist and
everything that I did say right and he's
saying no I got banned for covet
misinformation that's what he was saying
at the beginning of the clip wait for
real yeah wait hold on let me watch that
it makes more sense right like dumbass
for coveted misinformation and election
misinformation oh you're right yeah yeah
he's correcting oh correcting the record
here okay okay sorry sorry I got that
wrong brother
you got banned for
covid and election misinfo
but what about that can't be true I
actually I don't believe you I think
that it was all involved I do because he
got banned right after that thing when I
remember that I I assumed it was from
that too but it was 100 seems to be uh
saying otherwise so the chronology was
that this thing happened and then this
dude Nick is not green made a video yeah
and then he got banned so
suck on my tiny Jewish dick you [__]
demon ghoul
scream into the empty Halls of Rumble
you loser
also get better H ADHD footage that [__]
sucks stop lying to my [__] name
Christy's here
did he get a croissant
yo
he's so cute he's so amazing he's the
greatest yeah so awesome it's crazy how
much he looks like you he's showing
everybody his toy Teddy's here
what you got Teddy
you're making cool clay sculptures
can I show it let me see what is it
it's like a
censored looks like a lollipop a pretzel
lollipop
yeah
that's cool I love that that's so cool
this Clay is really fun do we have this
at home we should do this at home with
the clay
we should bring some home so we can play
with it later
this Clay is really cool okay Bruce was
completely quiet before you got in Ethan
now he has not stopped yeah
oh my God we have a lot yeah whatever
children right now
[Music]
wow what is that
oh you guys got a Happy Meal
this is a Happy Meal oh yeah it is
that's pretty cool Brucey wants everyone
to see this
that's awesome dude
that's great I'll show that Teddy made
this you want me to hold it up
I'm thinking we can see it
that's cool very nice
there it is
and the back there's a green piece right
here
oh Shredder's eating wow it's all
happening here this is all happening we
got dogs gaming
[Music]
better's always been a picky eater but
because of his kidney condition it makes
it even trickier and he's eating this is
a special moment it's a special moment
let's all enjoy powerful
so did you what kind of Happy Meal did
you get Teddy
careful
you got a snake toy okay what did you
eat
Shredder goes here
yeah
did you get nuggets or a hamburger
nuggies nice
good choice
all right I'm gonna keep doing the show
but you can hang out if you want okay
[Applause]
you got milk nice
french fries nuggies and apple slices
and a toy
nice
wait did it really come with clay
yeah I was like that's a crazy cool I
don't know this thing
you got a little something okay okay we
like that
he got a little clay
cool
you used to think from the Happy Meal on
that awesome
very cool dude
so uh anyway thank you to snico who uh I
think we're on the same page actually
after we cleared that up I think we're
in agreement yeah
so if it's defamation sue me dummy
what are you going to do you already got
banned idiot what damage could I do to
you
sue me please I love spending money on
attorneys it's my favorite [__] past
time
just take all my money attorneys
speaking of which
I'm waiting for an email about some
other [__]
seeing in these articles that he was
also banned on Instagram Twitter and
Tick Tock so
he must have really done something
stupid eh yeah
that's what I think too
anyway also something kind of fun
uh Andrew Tate's uh
let's call it his uh
predecessors this these are the alphas
he leaves to us the world to deal with
this is what's happening I guess in high
school
a child of Andrew Tate let's see what it
looks like
[Music]
this punch stuff is going to stop
you're not going to tell me what I'm
going to do
I am now the alpha you think teachers
are like handling kids with like
Kitty gloves now because they're afraid
they're going to come kill them
they're like yo this kid might have a
gun I better be cool about this
well not how this works
I am the teacher
the alpha takes priority over the
teacher you know if I take priority over
everything do you not know how that
works the teacher is telling the alpha
to sit in the seat right now and the
alpha doesn't have to listen to this
point okay
but the consequences that follow
are going to still apply to the alpha
the alpha doesn't take time
well this is just weird this is just
weird you're not [__] around
no serious he seems to be
I don't I don't know how to put this in
a way that uh I'm not gonna have to hit
the button on but yeah
very special let's just say if he were
to take a bus to school
there's
buses of different sizes that carry
different kinds of kids yeah not kinds
they're all kids you know they're all
equal and beautiful very special
but it's very special I don't know it
seems maybe you know not sure you guys
know what I'm saying
I'm trying to say something here y'all
follow loud and clear
so loud yeah and I'm not trying to be
mean or anything it's just he probably
he probably needs a little extra uh
care and attention and stuff like that
special kind of attention
Linus Tech tips
just kidding you know
the restarted Hardware
God
yeah but uh anyway this get this is what
I'm saying you can't get this kind of
Andrew Tate stuff into the hands of all
these kids they don't know what to do
with it
you can't just Proclaim I'm the alpha
Prince all it takes I'm the alpha
I feel bad for that teacher man I didn't
even deal with that [__]
yeah I don't know
I don't know disabled
right thank you chill out that was the
people guy not me
oh [__]
yeah but we love him hopefully he just
you know somebody explains to him that
it's a phase it's a phase yeah I'm just
gonna I know that's wishful thinking I
feel bad though because this kid's got
to live with this forever now this clip
it really is the thing these days isn't
it yes uh
it's different being a kid punishment
stuff
it's going to stop
I love that he's went up front and made
this proclamation to the whole class
that's confidence in a way right
I am now the alpha bro not how this
works and so this guy probably owns like
27 guns
a15s with armor-piercing rounds bump
stocks grenades
shotguns top G top G top G top G decals
on his a15s
probably got the Kevlar head to toe
yes sweetheart
you made a new one
let me see round two people let's see
that's so cool
you want to hold it up so they can see
oh wow
amazing beautiful colors amazing amazing
what colors
good job amazing amazing Daddy
yeah this kid is probably like yeah I'll
take uh 10 000 rounds of uh
armor-piercing bullets
um
I want the Kevlar face shield uh
military grade face shield
uh I'd like the if you guys have the
Tactical armor uh bulletproof shield
with the little glass I can see through
riot shield riot shield yeah
I tell you something like a Batman thing
right Shield I'm just calling it back
because it's called that in like uh
Rainbow Six or whatever yeah
they're like sure no problem
we got you he's like I'm the alpha yeah
okay cool and so you wanted the 25 uh
a15 I'm the alpha and my teacher
punishes me and I'm pissed off about it
okay so did you want the armor piercing
rounds or the hollow point
I'm [__] hate my whole class
I hope they die so did you want the
grenades like what kind of delay did you
want the five second delay or the 10
second
that's America oh boy
America is such a [__] joke
[Music]
armor piercing rounds of grenades
bathroom spring to show and tell the
class
[Music]
riot shields and handguns at 20
000 rounds of armor piercing bullets
[Music]
the SWAT team comes through the class
every week four drills on active
shooters
[Music]
with open arms and shallow Graves oh boy
kids are burying faster and faster each
day
that's America
specialty uh size uh uh caskets so we
can fit the kindergarteners too
sorry guys it's uncomfortable truth this
is what's happening out there three
[__] yeah whatever we have to get
onto that but that's what it is
that's what it is if my jokes offend you
then just imagine uh your kids being
killed at school now that's offensive
someone who works
[Music]
wait did you hit the button I just saw
Olivia's face and freaked out hey bubs
the man
oh cool let me see
oh Insurance Avery's screen oh yeah this
is oh people got a little tasty I love
it
wait what oh Avery's yeah yeah
um so we're back yeah yeah so I just saw
I don't know I was speaking off the top
I was riffing and then I saw Olivia and
she looked like horrified that's
something I said so I just I don't think
it was any I don't know it's better to
be safe it wasn't horrible I was just I
was shocked in the moment yeah
yes buddy
Pac-Man
package
picked
can I see
were people saying you missed it you
missed it
I don't think if that didn't work no no
no no no whatever whatever you guys
think it is wasn't what he buttoned so
well if they saw the slide then I didn't
miss it right yeah no they I think
they're assuming it was something that
got through but you guys know I get
worked up when it comes to this topic
yeah yeah it worked did it work it
worked yeah yeah everybody's saying fast
on that yeah
it works if everybody in the chat thinks
what got through was what it was right
right no that was then that wasn't that
was not it so yeah it was worse than
that I don't even remember what it was
come here Teddy it wasn't that bad it
wasn't I don't think it was Button
worthy to be honest yeah but whatever I
like you played it safe it was cool we
got the Avery screen
yeah it's wavery right so they can see
it
it's like a cool little horsey dude
packet
pick it
it's called is the name it's called
picket
picking coconuts in Barbados
um well that was fun I genuinely don't
even remember what I said I just saw
Olivia's face and panicked
it's a chicken
okay
love that for him
I'll remind you after the show what it
was what it was you can type it type it
to me don't type it don't type it no I'm
not going to read it I just want to know
you have like a compulsion to read
everything I won't I won't iron yeah
well I'll just hit the button again if I
read it
oh yeah that's I didn't think
again I think it was fine
uh well I didn't even finish what I was
gonna say that's it that's what I was
gonna say yeah
that one yeah I'm gonna say something I
don't I I probably shouldn't say
it's a little bit edgy
okay well let's get off the topic then
right
sensitive one to me yeah
um let's see
oh yeah but speaking of Angie Tate so he
got out of prison well not really he's
on house arrest it's not like he's a
quitter or anything this man put up
this shirt I guess
uh he needs money wait 130 bucks for
this [__] thing dude what
130 bucks
no shot he's selling this for 130. the
Matrix was released March 31st
1999 Andrew Tate was released March 31st
2023. do you understand now
do you understand now 131 dollars I
don't I I'm I'm afraid to admit I don't
understand
just that
what what's the significance someone uh
two things happened on the same day what
what okay
it's basically whoever there's some kind
of God
who made sure he was released on the
same day as the Matrix as to send a
subliminal message that the Matrix is
real and Andrew Tate is Neo apparently
someone uh although in The Matrix I'm
pretty sure Neo
runs away from the agents
and he's free you were right well I
guess they got him in the end
he wasn't in house arrest I'll tell you
that he was [__] surfing the web and
fighting monsters and [__] you're just
sitting at home smoking cigars yeah what
Zach sorry so there's a uh a tweet below
someone crunched the numbers as to why
the the meaning
oh we have an equation yeah
yeah but anyway he's put up 300 333 and
this man with all the fame and Power in
the world sold less than a thousand of
these in fact for 130 bucks you're
really sad to pay that for this [__] man
can you imagine seeing someone wearing
this like what would you think
I would think why am I on this Middle
School campus I should leave immediately
true
I think that's why I didn't sell them
either it's like his fans don't probably
his fans don't have credit cards how are
they going to order
I don't know Bradley Martin and how
those elk are pretty cool dudes that
like Tate
mom can I get this brand new uh t-shirt
it's 130 mom please Mom please please
please we have to free the top G please
and it's like he's still in a house
arrest investigation's still going he's
not free yeah he's on house arrest it'll
be kind of awkward if you paid 130 they
probably took his [__] passport too
because he knows that's what the Flight
Risk like he literally can't leave his
house dumbass
why they even selling 3XL I thought
they've hated fat people
really Jack dudes don't be by don't be
selling anything over 2XL brother
enabling fat fattiness let me check this
uh tweet
all right we crunched the numbers here
let's take a look
okay so my rest and release are one of
the largest events in cultural history
okay dude
that's [__] interesting considering
you sold 900 shirts
now released there will be two universes
choose your side
wow I choose lies I think this man might
be mentally ill I'm so smart you think
it's good receivable truth first lies I
don't think he's well you people are not
thinking about the question
okay so here's the math and this guy
seems to be serious
three thousand three hundred thirty
three shirts at 131.
you times those together that's
400 36 623
four plus three plus six plus six plus
two plus three equals 24. 24 years since
the Matrix was released
wow
math checks out the math checks out
again the significance of that math is a
little lost on me but well we already is
right I mean he set the number it wasn't
like a cosmic coincidence he said the
number
you know that's a good point too yeah
I think this guy might be mentally ill
uh Keck Central it just seems to be some
delusional thinking going on here I
don't know if anyone's noticed that
special so congratulations to um
oh God here's more
dude imagine seeing this
that's the game resist the slave mind
take my court buy this shirt for 130
dollars
resist the slave mind pay for me fifty
dollars a month for hustle University
where I teach you [__] you can learn on
YouTube for free stop the Sun from being
hot dude I cannot imagine wearing this
shirt you're gonna have to explain why
Neo I mean why Morpheus is white that's
the only commentary I feel like you're
gonna get on this
if they don't know who Tate is
well he's half black
yeah Tate's half black
true but I'm a mask wait he's morphy yes
what's up
stand by everyone apologies
I have an important update
mm-hmm
you're gonna do dinosaurs with the clay
okay
oh
he is just
mm-hmm
that sounds super fun we can do that
when I get home together that'll be so
fun he was laying out the master you
guys gonna play and painting are you
gonna do it in the basement or in the
kitchen
the coffee table oh by the couches
okay that sounds fun
are you guys going home are you
are you gonna go home soon so yeah bring
all the fun clay stuff so we can
we can play
Theodore ladies and gentlemen Give It Up
a lot to say today I understood more of
that than xqc
uh she had the building constructive but
just to watch any communities people
always been turning across let's just
mean
yeah that's in that's I thought I
understood that but I don't
so uh let's move on to our
main segment we're having so much fun
here
I mean there's Trump updates but that's
all over the news let's just con let's
just do
what we're all here to do wish to learn
about
well what why doesn't everyone get in
their position okay okay go to the
bathroom I'll be right back but we're
gonna set up Olivia's
87 page 83 page slide about uh Selena
Gomez
Haley Bieber drama the six people who
don't care
as a matter of fact seven yeah because
we put lovebot over there as well so
love will also be seven people who don't
care I'll be right back subjected to
this
um
all right all right we'll get everybody
over there in the meantime you guys can
you guys can all cruise let's see I'm
gonna make a fresh cup of coffee because
I feel like I'll need it for this so oh
I'll join you guys I made coffee like an
hour ago and it's probably still sitting
over there can you grab it I got you Dan
thank you Cam he's such a sweetheart
isn't he people gosh it's such a
sweetheart Amanda Cooper said this kind
of heals my inner child I know you're
being recorded but my dad will yell at
me and make me feel like an
inconvenience when I talk to him that's
uh yeah that's unfortunate
Dad should definitely be encouraged
encouraging to their uh kids interest
you know and Ethan's very good
Ethan's uh Ethan seems like a good dad
from everything I've observed I will I
will give him that yeah let's adore
again is Olivia right here or no in
Ethan's spot in Nathan's spot yeah
uh
uh Percy Jackson is finally getting
adapted into a show soon so Harry Potter
could suck it that's why I'm talking
about there's so many good
fantasy franchises out there that have
interesting wizard magical stuff going
on and we don't we don't need this donut
okay reliving Harry Potter over and over
again we've we've moved past the need
for Harry Potter as a society I think
we've gotten everything culturally that
we're gonna Plumb from that we live in a
society thank you I agree spoken like a
true Muggle
that's very insult that's like somebody
who can't do magic right
it's very insulting crazy uh just want
to give shout out to the crew for get me
through every week I Can't Get Enough
hell yeah Stephen thanks for being here
being here
um
if any of my middle school students show
up in that shirt I'm gonna bully them
yeah
that might be the answer I don't know
I mean I think back to when I
was a little [__] in middle school which
I definitely was and like I don't think
I ever would have gotten sucked into
Andrew Tate I I was never like that or
anything but
it does
it does make me wonder because I just
know how kids that age are and like I
feel like they're constantly telling
them no
probably just makes them like triple
down on their love for him I don't know
it seems like we have a lot of teachers
in the audience if anybody uh
disagrees with that but I mean obviously
you can't encourage it but I just feel
like oh thank you for the coffee
but you know it's just like you
especially a like a 12 or 13 year old
you tell them like oh you shouldn't like
this I feel like that's just gonna drive
them right into his arms uh
but what do I know no to top G yes to
Zach Lewis live at the Rocks that's 13
all ages very true that's very true
uh Olivia I'm so excited for this I
stand Selena thank you for doing all the
work
love you
uh Cameron is always a cutie but he's
looking fine hot damn
camera is very nice not me no way dude
no way can we can we get some love for
Olivia and chat she's she's a little
nervous right now
don't tell them uh thanks guys
our professor today right you're going
to be teaching us all about it yes I
told Sam this earlier I'm here today not
to prove that I'm crazy but to prove
that I am right and she's going to prove
she's not crazy by showing us her 90
page PowerPoint about online
I'm not here to prove that I'm crazy I'm
here to prove that I'm right and if in
that it proves that I'm crazy we can
have the conversation right that's crazy
are you out of your mind that's very
fair that's a separate conversation
whether or not you're crazy to to care
about this I think some of the places
you Source it from are from crazy people
you sent me 100 you've sent me some
citations already I've been on the dark
web what's that one Instagram page
you're always like uh
referencing
like some news drama page oh she can't
give away her sources oh well excuse I'm
just kidding I don't know are you
talking about Dum wall yeah
[Music]
one time in this she's in here
that one is pretty out there
dumois
Whitney Cummings was here he said that
they they reported accurately on her
taking the cheese off of all of her
Pizza matching it up with her fingers
and then eating it no way yes yes I love
it uh no I remember her saying that I
also remember some people uh with a
little conspiracy theory about that
whole incident
you know what I'm talking about
I think I do
but she sent it herself
that she sent it herself so you know
it's accurate then interesting Who would
know better um
this is just a theory okay don't put
that on me I don't know I don't know
anything I just recall there being some
talk I know nothing about nothing yeah I
don't know nothing about nothing I
literally just can't wait for all of
this to exist somewhere out here as well
like all of the information has been in
my head and whenever you guys say stuff
like oh no like wait where am I over
with us okay
is that okay yeah all right
oh do you want to
I mean you can Ethan you can sit
wherever you like
Teddy's coming for an encore
all right we're just getting situated
here stand by everybody
what you got in the bag
that's all clay oh my gosh
all right uh and then one last uh Dono
just uh Abigail saying hey crew I just
recently turned 21 can I get a happy
birthday shout out Zach you know what to
do
21. [__] you thank you so much you go
put it by um
I guess go put it by the table and then
so we don't forget it we'll bring it
home okay Teddy's cracking me up today
all right your mommy drove separately so
you can choose so Olivia uh are you all
set up
you have it open and pulled over the
screen and all that good stuff
okay
uh Porter Steel donated ten dollars and
said uh made a copyright free Funk song
for you guys if you're willing to listen
to it uh email it to us excuse me
what what
you are you going to take the Play-Doh
to the house
all of the clay you're not gonna leave
any for me
you gonna leave some for me so I can
make some dinosaurs thank you so much
what a generous kid
what a generous kid all right I think
we're all good and I need to go over
there too so
um shall we uh shall We join us Dan all
right join us all right
Shall We Begin
uh let's see cam we're waiting for Dan
yeah we could we can get started how's
the audio quality it's okay
yeah it's okay sounds good it sounds
like overhead mics but you can hear us
it's all good
Okay so
the great halina timeline we are here to
tell the truth about Selena Gomez and
Haley Bieber
so let's get a few things out of the way
before we begin number one Selena and
Haley are both people they both have
feelings they haven't committed any
crimes as far as we are concerned it's
none of our business who ends up with
whom romantically including all of these
instances there are no Mass offenses
it'd be awesome if some of us could stay
married and quiet but we don't seem to
be doing that so we need to to talk
about something are you talking about me
uh you stay married and Loud too also
but this isn't about you
um so real quick I'm sorry if we have
questions
100 just chime in whenever
okay maybe raising the hand would be
maybe funnier okay I like the imagery of
that
you can call on us beautiful yeah I love
it in between my legs
okay there you can see him yeah I'm fine
I think thank you though thank you for
the offer all right so we have uh
okay I follow I'm following why is this
worth talking about that's a big
question that is a huge question it's
because this is one of the first
relationships whose digital footprint is
saturated with evidence
and I think
cutie he always drinks out of my water
um okay all of the data is available
um these celebrities were young at the
time at especially towards the beginning
and they did not understand the
permanence of social media
so they weren't sub-tweeting as much as
they are today oh so we can't blame
anybody for any of this and it's all
good we should just let it go no oh yeah
what's up Zach I thought that's what you
were doing
subtweeting is when you post something
online directed at a person but you
don't say their name oh I didn't know
that oh yes so that's what subcuting is
when you like diss someone in a tweet
but you don't at them but people are
like I'm pretty sure she's sub tweeting
Selena when she says that is sub short
for something subtweet
what about like sub is a common prefix
that you put before
yeah but stuff would go like underneath
but it's not underneath you know I don't
know sadly I don't have the answer to
that one like below like substitute
subliminal that I like a subliminal
tweet that's good all right beautiful
next let's talk parasocial relationships
for a minute
I am aware of the fact that I probably
have one with Miss Selena Gomez okay
let's start I like the disclosure
civilization is established 14 000.
we've gone back we've gone back too far
what too far I'm kidding no July 2009.
wait hold on two back too far back
had even officially met and Selena was
on a Disney Channel show Justin had just
been signed by Scooter Braun he was
doing a radio interview and one asked
who his celebrity crush was he responded
with Selena Gomez okay Selena told Ellen
we have a clip of that do you want to
watch it or do you want to oh go okay
let me take as long as it takes to get
through this basically I mean we're
taking the scene the thing is though I
care so much I care so much about you
guys seeing the things so
she's fine she's fine you have a crush
on like in this industry if you've met
him or not like who's one person that
you like have a Crusher if you saw that
you would like oh crush on
Selena Gomez there we go
okay very cute very soon how old is he
he was very young 15 maybe my friend
haircut yes Ian had that area that's the
Smosh haircut right I was popping at all
times back then so Selena went on Ellen
there were rumors of them dating she
told Ellen that Justin is like her
little brother why do they know each
other yeah they had gone to a few events
together and he knew of her because she
had a Disney Channel show
so Ellen asked if they were dating Ellen
asked because there were photos of them
at events but they weren't publicly
dating and they hadn't been dating
they're like 12. that was my concern you
knew
yeah that is weird that is weird when
they first started officially dating she
was 19 and he was 17. okay
so I guess
why is Ellen crying a teenager
relationship none of your business
cancel Ellen she's not they weren't even
teenagers yet cancel her show you think
they were nine years old 12
who said 12. I thought someone said 12.
I feel like they they were probably like
13 or 14. well they no they started
dating when Selena was 19 he was 17.
yeah but that in this clip she's young
no this is the year before
the year before this is them kissing
okay ready okay okay okay so what did
you so Selena literally said this in
October and then it's January Justin and
Selena are kissing on a yacht January
2011. Justin Selena were spotted on a
yacht breaking the hearts of many
including yours truly and then I put my
name in yellow because I didn't want to
make it about me okay wait how were you
during this
I was in like third grade
I was 11. yeah and you were heartbroken
yeah a little bit I was aware of it and
I was moved
oh yeah yeah okay hey and Melissa wasn't
Jonathan Taylor Thomas that could piss
me off yeah
Cameron is one less lonely girl about
Selena
I guess today it's Haley
yeah yeah yeah there's nothing like us
about Selena because that song said oh
maybe Ethan so Justin sealed the deal in
a way because he went back if you go
back he's like I like this girl right
then she's like ew he's like my brother
interesting but then a year later or
even a few months later he sealed the
deal yeah
no that might get claimed yeah good one
that was my question did we check all
these
uh is I love you like a love song about
Justin I assume so yes and what Selena
Gomez and
scene
beautiful work Zack
yes Dan this is Selena Gomez she's a uh
singer actress and singer yes and
um
entrepreneur and also
um very charitable she do summer stock
yeah hey put your hand up I'm in line
what's up Ethan I was thinking what do
you I was thinking that I will have I
have leftover beans and rice for dinner
and I was just thinking I'm gonna mix
those together with some salsa and I've
got chips and I'm looking forward to
that yeah
um objection relevance yes
that sounds good uh well it's at my
house I would share it otherwise send it
via
okay can we go to the next slide I would
love that thank you so much
okay pics of a happy couple through 2011
most of 2012. only one year they dated
one and a half
well no no this is the first time are
you kidding okay yeah yeah
you want to look at all of them yeah of
course take your time this isn't America
while we're looking at this Zach can you
come bump the audio just a hair on that
Mike thank you
so are we liking what we're seeing they
did a lot together they're going to
award shows we did a lot together
they're cute they're being cute you know
uh right in this window of time I uh
serve them at my table at my restaurant
oh my God what restaurant California
Pizza Kitchen what they get do you
remember I no definitely not were they
nice big tip uh I remember you know what
this might contribute something to the
story
um Justin didn't seem that happy to be
there or into her that's the way that is
that was my officer okay Dan misses all
who is she oh yeah I have a fresh hot
first account team I'm just interesting
well you are talking about how difficult
their relationship wait what was that
what was the tip I don't remember I
think it was good though this wasn't
that good if you didn't remember it well
it's celebrities they're pretty reliably
tip well because they know they're going
to get slammed if somebody exposes them
or whatever okay now's your chance all
right are we ready there's a lot yeah
I said wait because Drew is Justin
Bieber's brand but we don't have to talk
about it I'm just noting that that's
really interesting
wait go back go back she's wearing a
smiley a smiley face shirt and that is
his brand true sucks why is it called
drew his middle name is Drew
yeah it's they both have happy faces I
know but he so you know he licensed he
has the happy faces they're like the
most aggressive licensers ever wow and
so he has to commission that like that
happy face from them that's so
interesting when was this though when
was which this I really feel like we
skipped some time oh no we we're just
this is a side note there was a time
schedule look at the pics
2011 2012 his brand hasn't been around
that long that's why I was asking right
girl we're we're at a different I said
wait outside now yeah yeah okay so
Jelena breaks up for the first time
November 2012. Jelena Justin was
performing at the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show November 7th and became a
little too flirty with model Barbara
Palvin who's famously engaged to Dylan's
Press today wait that's the same girl in
both pictures no no no oh Miranda Kerr
is on the bottom it's highly speculated
that this is the night she he also
allegedly hooked up with Miranda Kerr um
she was married to Orlando Bloom at the
time um wait which one who the one next
to he hook up with both of them you say
both in the same night allegedly so he
hooked up with both of them on this trip
it's a legend well you'll see that I
have I have I have evidentiary support
later in the yes but that I mean that is
kind of a lot because that's like two
cheating events on one weekend at the
same event that's pretty ballsy I mean
was he considered Bugatti Biebs at this
time or I don't know much better I have
a question yeah Sprouts the one that
went I'll call her daddy
no that's coal yeah yeah he got bodied
for that didn't he yeah it's so cringe
it was cringe can we pull it up you want
me to I'm actually curious so there's
two of them I never watched The
Magnificent Tales of Jeff and Cody or
whatever the [__] is gone
I'm too old for this spin-off but um so
I don't know anything about those guys
but I did see that everyone was goofing
on one of them for smoking during call
me Daddy they didn't know how to smoke I
listened to that whole podcast episode
the whole thing was cringe really what
what about it the way he was talking
about it he was like reading a wit text
book it was very strange do you
understand was he trying to be cool
yeah trying too hard to be cool thanks
what are the views like on this these
are this is just from the clips Channel
but this is on the clutch Channel though
four weeks ago pretty good better than
our collection it's got to be where that
big yeah yeah
open the door I don't know people get
people oh this guy
smoking weed in like a studio
and everyone who gets like this it's
fine it's [__] fine I'm curious yeah
did you even go to like something you
couldn't wait I mean right you couldn't
wait
to have a cigarette
cigarette I mean if she was smoking and
he joined in I'd get it
do we know where
she probably it's probably minimized can
you three fingers to the right put three
fingers on and then three three fingers
to the right one put three put three
fingers on Crash Pad yeah yeah
I'm doing okay
three fingers to the right everything
you do with bye it's like a Tupac rhyme
Zach what did you feel what did you
think about the smoking
on on that show I believe you had some
opinions
the poser
remember if that was the take at the
time
what did he say yeah I said it looked
like he didn't know how to smoke a
cigarette I'm pretty sure you said he
looked like a badass
oh you're right I have no Recollections
yeah he does [__] wait is that the one
that's engaged to the model though no
different it's the other twin so is that
the lame twin
which I don't know is there a lame one
in Nicole no they're both not really
they're both cool
magnificent Mississippi
okay ready yes
um actually one quick note I was on
monitoring the chat just to make sure
that you know there isn't a problem with
the audio again or something and I'm
seeing a lot of people saying stop
interrupting Olivia let her speak
we need to make the goal of this clear
her whole job is to make us interested
in this yeah if we're not asking
questions are you I'm not going to give
bro don't get them that's done yeah no
I'm doing a show here dummy I think I
think I should just make it clear this
is this is the goal is to get us
interested and let me tell you something
I am so excited for when you guys start
asking questions
um that I'm like excited to answer you
know about like stupid follow the gossip
okay so I love questions Jelena breaks
up for the first time 2012. this is also
the night that he hooked up allegedly
with Miranda Kerr you'll see later in
this uh slideshow he gets into a
physical fight with Orlando Bloom in a
few years oh [__] yeah
I don't know it's a preview whoa we have
a fight with Legolas you know Orlando
boom he's
hungry what about so people say he's
hung no there's a picture he's got it
didn't look that big to me really
there's an Orlando Bloom it was like a
flash he was like he was on a wakeboard
with uh Katy Perry with his dick like in
her [__] face
I mean it was flaccid it didn't seem
like anything crazy the uh the elves are
uh blessed
I don't understand how people look at
floss a dick and they go he's hung I
mean well you know I get an impression
you know the showers and Growers right
just didn't seem like much I feel like
he he's a shower definitely can we pull
it up off screen if you guys
I'm just curious what it looks like at
this point do you actually want to see
if everyone's okay with it I can pull it
up just close your eyes if you don't
want to see it Dan
could I ask this did she is he upset
about this photo being out there does he
not care
I mean it was like a don't show it
obviously oh he's he's out there proudly
he's actually naked I thought he was oh
he's butt ass naked yeah don't show it
it wasn't it this is weird show me the
show me the thing I got it if you want
no he's [__] cut he's like super fit
that's wild
dude that's a haunt it looks almost like
coconut a sausage how can you say he's
not hung dude it's not it's like out
there okay
[Music]
it's strange it is it almost it's it's a
it's European a lot of people are into
that stream I don't find it impressed
I'm not impressed it's kind of shoved up
though I think it's shoved up bro yeah
it looks a little chubbed up he looks
like he shoved it up a little bit before
the photo nah I got it I got it pulled
up here if you don't you don't worry
he's semi shopping don't worry I think I
think that might [__] up a little bit
because he knew the cameras were there
as possible
or they could have just been post coil
s
okay this slide has the first bit of I
think compelling juicy evidentiary
support the next day the two Justin and
Barbara saw The Lion King together
um the photo below was posted and
quickly deleted by Justin's friend but
he didn't delete it quickly enough
because Selena Gomez posted it on her
Twitter with the caption dot dot dot dot
dot dot
completely lost yeah I'm lost
that's just how you you used to post
photos on Twitter back in the day right
um
built in so he went to see Lion King
with his friend in the back is this girl
she went with them as well okay his
friend posted this of the three of them
together quickly deleted it Selena Gomez
posted it was obviously angry about it
so that's the kind of caddy that she
posted that online it's a little bit
messy yeah sure messy although I don't
know what happened if she if he cheated
I guess go get him girl no I say this in
here Selena Selena's messy she's not
gonna say she's wrong but I do think
that they were broken up at this time
not yet not confirmed
if you're posting online about your
boyfriend that's okay no you'll see okay
okay same outfits same day Justin Bieber
is dating Selena Gomez at this time
Jelena then officially splits after
nearly two years together she broke up
with him about a week ago A source told
people at the time with them being a
part it got complicated she had some
trust issues it's not easy but the
relationship needed to end all of Selena
Gomez's friends on Twitter were posting
her eventual Kidney donor said what a
fool her co-star said that's why you
don't Rob the Cradle because babes be
tripping
um her friend what does she mean rub the
Cradle it's because Selena's older than
Justin
okay how much older is she two years
um okay I want to call that Rob in the
Cradle yeah I want to point out that
we're still over a decade ago okay we're
in 2012. I have a lot of questions so
which uh which slide are we on because I
think our rule is every 10 slides we'll
do a temperature check how everyone's
feeling right every 10 slides we'll do a
temp check we're on 13. but we can I
think we can call for a vote at any time
but I'm I'm in I'm I'm all the way in
I'm in I mean I guess I'm in I'm in what
else are we going to do also if that if
it if that changes let me know Dan says
what else are we gonna do is that you
saying I'm in it yeah yeah nothing but
crazier from here okay don't worry
crazier than what a fool are you kidding
me so what who's this Kidney donor
yes daddy
she needed a kidney and this woman just
gave her one it was her best friend oh
okay it's her bestie yeah
um so my favorite sweetheart what you
got is that a McDonald's toy
is it somebody gave me
[Music]
um it's like a dancing Pokemon
oh is it Mario toy
okay so okay and then my favorite tweet
was from the guy who played her dad on
Wizards of Waverly Place and he said he
did not know how to sub tweet all women
should be treated with respect listen up
boy at Selena Gomez I just want to give
a quick shout out to David DeLuise his
dad was a legend Obsessed the goat dude
Cannonball Run himself
who are these people dude okay
wait go back
okay so
um
all women should be rich he's suggesting
that
Justin was disrespectful yes okay David
okay David okay a few months later in
January Selena and Barbara pose together
Selena who was definitely drunk at a
party confronts Barbara it was the
Golden Globes after party
um I said kill him with kindness cell
love you because that's a song that she
has it's assumed the flash HD photo was
intercepted by either of their teams
because it was never printed now is that
underage drinking
Lion King he's also friends with Selena
no justice they met they met Selena
approached her at a party and it was
photographed what's the kill em with
kindness cells that your editor that's
my editorial um Edition yes Teddy
it's just so chaotic okay cool that
sounds good we'll play with that too
with the clay
we'll make a clay castle for him
that sounds fun that's fantastic
just clay dinosaurs okay we have to do
the castle
um so what's the significance of this
photo just that they met it's at Selena
okay bubs
it's that Selena and Barbara clearly had
contention and then a few months later
they were photographed together and it
was it was it was a cultural reset at
the time okay okay I understood just
okay
and then there's a dirty there if you
care about watching this I'll just say
like I do okay you care about me
absolute she was having fun
super elegant what are you wearing
can we turn it up we need to keep the
monitor kind of quiet
oh I see I see that it's not fired okay
that's fair go ahead Versace
did you choose it yourself or whatever
yeah I did I mean
okay this is supposed to be evidence
that she's like wasted drunk because she
said well together
the slide to me
hold on this slide
doesn't seem necess doesn't seem like
yeah I got no problem with her there
well she's trying to introduce this
hypothesis that she was only willing to
uh interact with this Barber girl in a
semi-friendly way because she was
intoxicated but this is the same event
yeah yeah and here she is well this is
before
one piece of evidence is
a little I'm a bit confused
but also I don't think so because the
rest of the internet okay Selena throw
shade adjusted March 9th Selena released
a dancing video with her friends called
everybody knows your boyfriend is a
douchebag that was an existing song she
choreographed the dance to it okay
Selena and Justin are back together in
April he posts this and deletes it on
his Instagram she flew to Oslo to visit
him wait wait wait so he posted it and
then quickly deleted it did we know they
were back together no this is how we
knew and why did he erase it I think he
was just letting his fans know like
but then why not leave it up why not
leave it up yeah I don't know
he just but they were photographed in
Oslo okay Selena's friends were not
happy about this reconnection here's a
clip of Justin waiting backstage for
Selena at the bbmas and Taylor fake gags
as Justin pulls her away oh I think I
remember this was a huge Taylor is a
queen friend I think so she's friends
with Selena yes and they know they know
that Justin Bieber is a douche yeah they
do not approve
that's pretty ballsy of her to gag at
him intercepting and then
this is it possible she was doing about
something else because that is like so
wild no to just gag at somebody like
that I mean I mean it's props to her you
know maybe she had some bad shrimp
backstage and
she had like a she couldn't bring her
friend well that seems
indirectly it's trying to pull her away
she's like oh I don't like Justin dude
that's awesome that she hates him that
much you know I've seen interviews with
Taylor she seems like uh
she seems cool I like her I'm not I
don't listen to her music much
but I do like her it seems like she's
cool she seems like a great friend a
great friend saw an interview with her
where she was very funny and cool yes
okay so next June he hangs out with
model Jordan nizuna it's unclear if he
was being blatantly Unfaithful or if
they were open but it's reported hold
the phone
[Laughter]
what
going on here what is this picture it
was the it was the footage from they
went indoor skydiving and it was the
footage from inside the the location but
where is Justin laying on her lap what
how are you able to pull it out of this
hat and he's laying on her lap so did
the skydiving place leak this yeah oh
Shady yeah okay and so this is so how
long after their reconnection did was
this so this was posted in April the
bbmas were may this is June this
[__] couldn't keep it in his
pants for two bro it gets way worse what
a [__] okay so after this happens
Selena uninvites Justin to her 21st
birthday party I'll tell you I can't
believe they're 21. that makes me feel
like she's an idiot
okay he was walking around the front of
the event with a singular Rose in his
hand and then he had trouble at the door
and Selena's stepdad finally let him in
so that's him wandering around
you know it's like dude people really
don't want to see you in there by the
way yeah like those are all her friends
they all hate you dude so outside inside
that's some sad loser [__] yeah so let's
get into it where was hey wait go back
I'm not done with this okay
this man really thinks he's Romeo
so I don't know dude he was big back
then he pretty much was Romeo I loved
him no it's the way he's like hanging
out under her uh balcony
like I don't know Juliet
Juliet
so he's got one rose and she finally
lets him in yeah Selena's stepdad
finally left her stepdad yeah it's
important oh her stepdad okay uh my dad
doesn't want you to come to my birthday
all right are we ready
where was Haley during all of this uh I
am so ready for this
training like Mr T like we had a met the
antagonist in the story we're like 30
slices okay so back in the day Haley was
a very big Justin and Selena Gomez fan
and luckily for us very active on
Twitter and got him she said I'm for
sure 100 team Jelena I don't care what
anyone says but Justin Bieber and Selena
Gomez together is the definition of a
Teenage Dream hashtag word hashtag word
Haley was based in 2011. so cute so kind
make Haley great again now uh Haley is
the daughter of which Baldwin
her dad is the really weird dumb one
who's like a born-again Christian God
is it Steve Stephen Baldwins was the one
that was with Paulie I think that's him
okay yeah he's a real he's like the F
tier Baldwin isn't there a billy bald
one pull up the picture of him for
reference so we know what each idiot he
is
although although I have to say Alec was
the cool one but now he's not that he's
also kind of a weirdo lamo he's a
murderer he's a murderer he's gonna
start a production back up with that
movie too yeah [__] do they really
yeah no way yeah they got it are you
[__] me when I saw that yeah they
did just let it go this this is her dad
I mean look at this ball this guy did a
lot of coke that's like the Baldwin
where the mom was drinking during the
pregnancy The Usual Suspects right
wasn't even that oh you know what uh he
is amazing I love that movie hahaha
he's got like no no neck
that is is the end
ing give it this changes everything hey
Zach too much I actually did not know
that she was a nepo baby I just I did
she actually pronounced James Baldwin
he's not like fun fact he's a boss
she is a nepo baby all the way are there
photos that went viral a few months ago
or weeks ago of her in a parking garage
wearing a shirt that said nepo baby
during all of that but wait I thought
that was a Photoshop I think that was a
guy that was real we need to fact check
that I think it was real it was stage
though I think yes
I've seen outside of the parking group
can we find out if that net can you fact
check that love you're the only one left
all right I swear okay because that's
crazy to walk around are we ready
because this is so important this is so
important you guys have no idea you're
gonna be shocked okay I had a cute date
no no no no flashback to February 13th
I'm problematic and very together Jelena
had a cute date nobody cheated on
anybody that night Justin post for
photos with fans who were waiting
outside of his hotel
Haley Baldwin was posted up caught in 4k
stalker Vision waiting for him in 2012.
he did not know her that's his future
wife I wrote what in the Wattpad I'm
obsessed foreign
I said it's weird but it's still sweet I
don't really think that she's a little
girl I wouldn't be like that whatever
but it is fun
yeah it's interesting how old is she
here oh I don't I don't know a minor
right yeah early teens probably yeah
early days um I
her family obviously has like industry
connections I'm wondering like why would
she have to wait outside to meet Justin
the the other Avenue to meet Justin
Bieber if she wanted to well she's also
seen on like carpets and stuff walking
like toward him but uh there are DMS
from the head of his New York fan club
who has DMS with Haley Baldwin asking
her where Justin James the fan clubs
you guys if you want if you want after
this I can send you guys that link to
that or wait click the link I want to
see it
we're the head of the judge the Justin
Bieber fan club the damn Club I got to
know where he's at what slider where is
he
I just want to watch this clip
it's not a clip it's a video
I think that's what it is that not the
same thing I mean yeah but it's like
longer
I don't want to watch the whole video I
just want to clip
like what dicks takes a clip 30 seconds
clip is part of video yeah
so it looks like she did wear the shirt
but when she she changed before she left
the parking structure like she got some
clothes just staged wait wait wait oh
you're talking about the nepo baby thing
yes yeah photo but staged encounter yeah
oh my God why would you do that she wore
it and then as she left she changed back
into just a plain shirt yeah because
she'd be psychotic to wear walk around
with that uh this is the video
[Music]
is this the president of the fan club
here yes oh the girl in the video yes
and she's showing her DMS with Haley
this is the prez yeah that's the
president
she also just as a side note if we're
gonna be doing this uh Justin and Selena
did a Call Me Maybe music video guys be
respectful okay I'm sorry I'm so sorry
sorry they were mouthing the words to
Call Me Maybe Selena and Justin and then
Haley and this girl read redid it
together that's weird yeah um Justin
probably gotta hate this girl she's like
straight stalking I've been following
his location who is the New York the
president I mean I feel like he loved
his Believers okay loves his Believers
okay it's not a crime to be a fan of
your husband No it should be though
except for me you know Anne Frank would
have been a believer too I know I
believe that with all my heart that's
right okay
I was a Haley most of you were too some
of you still are and that is literally
literally so okay
um basically here I'm just saying I
don't think that it's a fair argument to
say that Justin shouldn't be with her
because she was his fan your wife should
be your fan I totally don't have a
problem with it I loved Justin Bieber I
love Jack Harlow I love Pete Davidson if
I were lucky enough to be pursued by any
of those people I would have starred in
their documentaries the same way that
Haley starred in Justin Bieber's
documentaries
um I also wouldn't want to be compared
consistently with my husband's
ex-girlfriend especially in the grossly
physical descriptions people like to
offer up just reminding people what is a
valid critique however is it's not cool
to bully your husband's ex publicly and
consistently especially after being
married for years
um
the daughter of the shitty Baldwin Ailey
Haley she's the one who's being accused
of bowling yeah okay we're about to get
into that uh what side are we on
that's a good question
27 okay we're making progress here
I'll be listening
also let me know smoke cigarette yeah
you guys can do it
I just want to pose like I could have a
nicotine gum right people can't hear me
chewing from here
I think you have a nicotine guy what
flavor are you on the table come on yeah
is it helping yeah it's awesome you're
smoking less yeah good for you yeah I'll
take one it's not like mint it's like
bubble gum flavor that's cool except
when Olivia's talking about this stuff
oh yeah it goes outside and starts
smoking
oh you have to get it I thought you had
it on you yeah I have in my world too
good for Zach I'm glad he got on the gum
yay that's um
if you keep smoking at the exact same
rate but then is that actually it's way
way worse yes it's just way better
there's no link thanks there is no link
between uh nicotine garment cancer no no
you misunderstood what I said if you
continue to smoke at the exact same rate
that you were before but you just that's
not helpful right you're cute that's
like you'll get nicotine no that's not
well when I started that's what I was
doing
and you're like why am I doing this this
is insane you got the four milligrams
I'm about to faint
dude yeah I can't wait what the [__] is
this you got the flavorless one it's
bubble gum
oh there's flavor inside all different
chocolate mocha colored cream
yeah is
is Haley the less lonely girl or is
Selena the one less lonely I think it's
Haley it's Haley yeah this is important
they did it at their wedding party they
did it oh okay yeah it was Maria
what are we talking about here who's
Maria
no just to be written song called Maria
all right let's focus let's focus just
FYI we can hear the shooting I'm just
putting that out there [__] I'm not
it's under my lip love why are you doing
this well oh suck such BS dude I'm just
gonna hear me saying anything you can
only use specifically someone listen I'm
grazing who
it's the guy right by the mic dude
you're closer than I am look at someone
who sounds like he's making out when he
eats you talking about me or Zach
the [__] are you talking about
you could ask anyone here
I never heard that but I don't I guess I
don't watch that boys
you know to tell you the truth I don't
really have that impression of Zach
thank you Dan [__] good guy right
here [__] you I mean you might do it I'm
not saying that you don't choose it's
not an absolute yeah you're not
something I made an observance does
anyone co-sign what Amy said one person
I do yeah I have like ADHD so that stuff
like that bothers me but you don't even
you're not even here you're not
when I was there when he was
listen listen I am I can put it aside uh
if you want to do it though okay so the
person that's in the room and one that
is halfway across okay
you sit by Zach thoughts
I Zach I I love you okay I it I notice
it sometimes it does not bother me
though okay it's okay you do choose Zach
it's fine oh Ian backs it up too okay
there it is I'm a human I know what do
you want I want to put on my hat well
it's better to know than not no no right
I wouldn't know if you were human it's
very um
I'm a [__] horse
look let's move what's Olivia what slide
are we on yeah
[Music]
are you crazy are you out of your mind
Ethan is completely invested I could
tell okay I'm not going anywhere yeah
okay please let me know if you are done
you know you're not supposed to chew it
Zach you just put it under your lip and
let it rest there and then you chew
that's what the instructions are
ready yeah go ahead please sir okay
Haley's first diss to Selena on Twitter
was April 2013. this was after their
first breakup when Selena posted that
dance video which albeit Haley made a
point kind of it was a bit immature that
Selena posted this can I can I just
point out
that tweet is from April 6th
that's tomorrow
that's insane what does that mean
if you do two plus two which is how uh
there are many people are on this couch
plus two which is how many dogs I have
right
whatever I don't have the energy to
finish that
um oh we have a question
um and to the people calling me immature
what what were they calling her immature
I can't find the first tweet but
everybody uh
this is the one that everybody everybody
has in relation to this so
just to make sure I understand yes
Selena
choreographed yes this music video about
everybody's a douchebag and she posted
it yeah but on her YouTube channel on
her YouTube channel but like is it a
stretch to she didn't write the song
um it was right when they broke up
it was right when they broke up yeah I
just I just want to throw a loop for the
date thing it could be like in the UK
you know they put the Dave and the month
could it have been uh the 4th of June
you know like maybe they are American so
probably not I don't know
um okay December jelena's not talking he
says that they're not talking
Kardashian Jenner Gomez Baldwin Bieber
Saga Begins it's March 2014. go back
usually
this is in December they aren't speaking
go back
where to where no to the one where
they're not speaking Yeah so he says
they're not on talking and he comes out
with an album or a single you're all
that matters to me interview he says he
still loves her yes we'll play it okay
[Music]
we are going to hit
prison
in a great place um in my relationship
here we go um
now is this a real story like you was in
a great relationship for real this is
true really though is that with SG all
right it really was
um
he's really opening up here he's being
bonus okay I've seen it up thank you but
what a douche I mean you cheated on her
so many times just get real dude move on
loser ready
okay
The Saga Begins
you okay is that do you want to check in
I'm in you're in okay all right okay
give me a little buzz it won't hurt my
feelings I literally swear to God
no nobody's turning on you
we're good okay so we're gonna regroup
so
it's in the talks of switching her
managers from her mother to Kris Jenner
who we know who Kris Jenner is
so that's her hanging out with Kendall
more and more because of this connection
oh so Selena was friends with Kendall
you'll see yeah yeah
wait did she end up signing her soul to
Chris she did not she doesn't Selena was
going to hire Christian they were
talking about it okay okay Coachella
Selena was hanging out more and more
with them so she went to Coachella with
them Justin met up with them Selena and
him were spotted kissing that's them at
Coachella Selena
yes Teddy
face paint so cool are you a dragon or a
dinosaur
[Music]
you look awesome
awesome
[Music]
it's Bruce's pretty sure it wasn't clay
yeah
that's so fun you did that with Lena
oh good luck Lena
okay so they went to Coachella and then
Justin and Selena are back making out
yeah they were kissing that Coachella
interesting the week following
what's this photo on the right that's
Justin and Selena photo that a fan took
of them in the crowd what was the lineup
at Coachella you know that's actually
something I don't know was Justin
performing no oh not as far as I were
he's too cool for that yeah
um got it week following Coachella
Selena deletes all of her photos with
the car with the Jenner Sisters and
unfollows them on Instagram whoa it is
alleged that Selena found sexy pics sent
to Justin on his phone from both Kendall
and Kylie separately she unfollowed the
girls on Instagram deleted all their
photos okay hold on that's a lot yeah is
how why are we speculating that it's
just a toy they're cool I know but oh
very they don't want to hear that that's
such a great sound because that is what
is speculated speculated by who because
that's a huge yeah that they both were
sending him nudes like that's intense
and then TMZ reports on it that she says
that she has enough toxic people in her
life so she [__] up some way yeah and
something happened just you'll see how
much worse it gets with with this
situation okay so she unfriended them
yeah in a sense she threw the first
Gauntlet publicly in a sense
okay so Khloe Kardashian tweeted this it
says you want to play in the 20 year old
pool well I'm still in my 20s and I'm
better at this game than you don't [__]
with my little sisters Chloe like who
cares about Chloe like oh you're
literally like uh you were old probably
go back what do you want to see this is
good drama oh got it give me a second
Chloe so she is tweeting
and this is obviously about her this is
like a huge yeah going on yeah what does
she mean playing the 20 year old pool
like what how many years old
like you want to pretend like you're an
adult
20 year old pool 20 years
old yo you want to hang with us it's
like high school bullying yo you want to
hang with us 20 year olds the seniors
it's so stupid
I'm gonna shove you like a locker
what the hell that sounds so stupid all
right next Selena declines Kris Jenner
as her manager pick someone else
you think she snubbed her because of the
controversy I am I had at least had
something to do with it
um what's all these photos though well
this is uh the person that she signed
with her husband ended up directing her
documentary my mind and me that released
this year okay so it was a good
partnership yes it was a great
partnership okay fantastic so Justin
allegedly has a history of being linked
to most of the Kardashian Jenner sisters
at some point in the 2010s he's rumored
to have been linked romantically to
Courtney Kendall and Kylie wait he
quoted three of them
[__] Court those were the rumors but
man's collecting like Infinities okay
okay hold on and it was pretty
mainstream reported like oh yeah okay
hold on hold on hold on that's so in the
middle the girl in the Bikini that's
Kendall and Justin posted that on
Instagram so I think it's fair to say
that they hooked up yeah the other two
seems pretty speculative
speculative but
I think it's true once you get Bugatti
he likes those things you'll see later
he posted at the time he was kind of
beefing with Scott Disick Kourtney
Kardashian's baby daddy and um people
think that a photo he posted was him
taunting Scott these people are so
immature it's crazy I like the 3D
glasses I do too you think they were
[__] with those on I don't know
definitely so the only sister he hasn't
had sex with is Kim or is there another
one Chloe Chloe Kim and Chloe that's why
Floyd was upset yeah
Josh you're a thing that's to have sex
with three sisters yeah that's [__]
nuts like why would that I think it's
the famous people world like their
worlds are so small
maybe it's a 3DS three dicks isn't
Courtney the oldest yeah how old is she
what's that age difference
she she was in the 20 year old pool oh
yeah she's 43.
she's 43. he's 43 right now and how old
is Justin
I mean he would have to be around 20 30
years old 29.
can someone crunch the numbers for that
I don't remember the numbers 14. 14 year
difference wow so if he was
this was definitely Robin Williams a
little bit disgusting yeah okay so
Justin teases fans that he and Celine
are back together he posts this deletes
it with our love is unconditional girl
you gotta stop taking him back it's so
yeah it's it's like I feel bad for her
me too what's with the posting and
deleting why is that happening it's a
thing
no I think it's like oh I'm being
secretive and I'm posting this on my
team doesn't or like maybe it's like
that I think they're just but I mean
it's there forever yeah he still has
some Selena Gomez post up on his
Instagram
yeah toxic relationship I mean even seen
Instagram look like that reminds me of
my own toxic relationship really kind of
like he doesn't want the girls to see it
but he wants Selena to like know he's
just being a little emo teenager yeah
yeah wait so go back let me just take
that in
so he's saying we're back together our
love is unconditional and we're we're
getting married yeah hold on back it up
a second so she correct me if I'm wrong
she she formed some sort of Friendship
with some of the Kardashian girls or
whatever but then they have a falling
out yeah and during all this
Justin was sleeping around with all the
sisters and then she took him back
it was a toxic relationship I don't
think they were together during that
some good no I know but like you do no
he's it's gross he's really
heartbreaking yeah he seems a lot
healthier and stable and happier now
just so sure I mean he's older and
mature I mean yeah again these are just
kids but that just seems kind of nuts to
uh
which Kardashian was the one less lonely
girl oh I think
um Kendall Kendall what are you asking
the one less there's gonna be One Less
Lonely Girl and I want to know which one
it was what does that mean one less
lonely girl it's a bib song and so and
so when you say it's Kendall what do you
mean by that I think that his choice for
One Less Lonely Girl if we're talking
about through all the Kardashian sisters
I think he'd pick Kendall okay so he
she's the one that's only girl the
Kardashians okay
um next Justin Orlando Bloom get into a
physical altercation July 2014. that's
whipped out his dog
so yeah Orlando at a club in Ibiza can
we pull up Orlando's dick again
he whipped it out as a sword player if
you'll remember in slide 11 Justin was
rumored to have hooked up with Miranda
Kerr around the time of the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show that I do it right
he was 29 he was only 18 by the way
um just after Bieber approached him they
got into a fight which was briefly
caught on video Let's watch it so wait
Orlando Bloom was dating her he was
married to her when they [__]
supposedly oh gross dude
baby he was is Justin Bieber technically
front of the show since he called in
once oh [__] I totally forgot about that
that was so weird that was very weird
that's wait what happened I totally
and and he just I think Justin called
him we just loved bombing Austin
yeah oh my God 45 seconds before you're
like wait is that Justin Bieber
yeah that was um
he is a friend of the show I guess right
I showed Justin Bieber yeah so let me
see these guys fight all right so there
are two different accounts that TMZ
reported one is that Justin extended his
hand to Orlando who then refused it and
when Justin asked what's your problem
Orlando mentioned Miranda Justin tried
to walk away Orlando swung that's from
Justin's team get him Orlando swung on
him okay
Justin said something to the effect of I
had sex with your wife and then
Orlando's that I believe that I believe
I totally believe that's what happened
there's no video
I was trying to hear killed for that
video yeah I thought uh
yeah there's a play button if you go
down keeps going this is the vid the
picture if you go down
there's a play button there yeah on the
left there yes oh is it oh oh
what's up
what's up [__] your wife bro it looks
like he's hitting a middle schooler I'm
sorry yeah
how tall is Justin Bieber you know what
five seven maybe even oh yeah I saw him
in person once behind uh at Austin's
show he didn't seem short
probably just his presence
giving me he's got a tall he's got tall
guys well he probably does have the
secret high heels that like yeah Cruz
wears
the lifts okay that is kind of
embarrassing though despite all that of
even if Justin said yo I [__] her wife
Orlando brooms like an adult yeah
and then that night swing it on a child
yeah a little bit with a weak swing too
a child who [__] your wife made it
worse by posting a photo with Miranda in
a bathing suit with the queen caption
and then he posted a photo of Orlando
Bloom crying dude he is such a caddy
Bear yeah
do you see what I mean when I say that
this relationship is so documented like
we have everything he's just yeah that's
good
yeah the thing that striked me about
Justin in particular about all these
people they're so immature but Justin in
particular is just such a douchebag yeah
imagine getting so I mean imagine
getting so famous so young I guess and
being so adored from at such a young age
you probably get a [__] up for sure
all of these
wild celebrities wind up like this yeah
this is pre-jesus Justin oh he found God
that's right things get very messy
summer 2014 it just became like frequent
that he would post photos of girls he
thought was hot and say like who is this
yeah
yeah the other one to the collection
like a very famous example is a few
years later a few years after this I
didn't include it because it would mess
up the timeline he posted a who is this
about you know who Wolfie Cindy is yes
yeah that's how that was her rise to
fame was he posted who is this yeah and
she's okay
fan of the show
no it's Dr Richard no there's Wolfie
there was like no that's the writer Dick
Wolf yeah blizzard Wolfie yeah
okay a traveling couple in September
Justin took Selena to St Martin and then
to Paris after their break and posted
this photo of her on vacation September
25th that's them at the airport in Paris
heartbreak in Paris September 2014.
after St Martin when they were in Paris
Selena went to an event without Justin
all right peep that's Miranda Kerr on
the left by the way that Selena's posing
with which is kind of awesome who's that
the girl that Justin and Orlando were
fighting over that's her on the left so
they had a fight in Paris and then you
know this hasn't happened yet they
haven't gotten a fight yet
Celine is at an event right now without
Justice yeah Justin while this event was
happening was photographed having dinner
with Kendall Jenner TMZ posted Justin
Bieber Kendall Jenner romantic dinner in
gay parade what the [__] Selena leaves
Paris right away without Justin same
hair same shirt as she had at the event
straight home yeah well no she went to
Texas to be with her grandparents dude
what is wrong with him yeah he's so
crazy she tweeted out we have to learn
the hard way sometimes she has learned
the hard way many times yeah I know
but I do want to say that also Kendall
is [__] giant b word dude like that
is some dirty mean girl [__] yeah
so he spent the third time hanging out
with them in Paris publicly for fashion
okay cool two months after Kendall drama
in Paris Selena forgives her and goes to
Dubai for New Year's December 2014. this
is the photo that people think he's
allegedly hooking up awkward at this
time
with piece of love I understand she's
the victim here but are you kidding me
she's so famous and she's so linked to
this their first love is dangerous yeah
it is and you celebrate how old is she
at this point 2014 how old is she only
23 or something give me a [__] break
people never get out of here the one
thing oh the one thing is like why is
she hanging out with Kendall like yeah
bro it gets worse
um so see this two months later yeah
this girl hooked up with her boyfriend
small it's a tiny world and you're in
the circle at this point it's time I
know so that picture in the bottom left
is like
who is that Cody Simpson that was G
that's no no I'm sorry bottom right
that's Justin and Courtney they're
hugging it looks like a girl Is
straddling him and people assumed that
it was Kourtney Kardashian what is the
Assumption there
because this photo was taken like the
same day or like the day before these
people are wild I don't know he was
taunting Scott Disick who was like
publicly having a breakdown about
Kourtney Kardashian why would he go from
like having this public relationship
with Kendall to then having sex with her
old ass sister bro
I don't know it's also all it's
speculated it's rumored
um it was a setup
while Selena was in Dubai with Kendall
hero's best friend in the entire world
Haley Baldwin was spending New Years
with Justin Bieber on vacation Selena's
best friend no no no Kendall's best
friend Haley okay so it's widely
speculated that the models orchestrated
getting Gomez away from Bieber to allow
Haley time with him over New Year's
because they were not friends after this
trip to Dubai
ever gone on a trip and then come home
friends that's my question I got that
vacation morning
yeah bro
so he was posting it all like he posted
this of them kissing it must have hurt
Selena very badly I'm sure yeah it was
him and Haley that's him and Haley yeah
he's so mean why is he so mean yeah I
know okay so she was on this trip
Selena was with Kendall in Dubai
then somehow
while she was in Dubai Haley and Justin
were on vacation together but they were
broke up weren't they it seems like they
were they were behind the scenes always
kind of on and off I don't think they
needed to cast her away I kind of I mean
it worked Kris Jenner orchestrated all
this yes okay and I have more evidence
to support this
um so Kendall was caught in 4k this year
in Dubai someone asks her if this is her
first time visiting she says my first
two times were horrible and then she
clarifies with her hands and goes
horrible this is fun so clearly
something happened on the trip do you
want to see it she went with Selena yeah
Mickey was gay
come on now
there we go
you'll see my first horrible
this is so fun oh yeah first two times
were horrible horrible oh yeah this is
fun
did you have to read her lips or like
the internet did it for me I didn't have
to that's definitely what she said yeah
there's no question about it so it's
horrible because she was only there to
trick or she doesn't like sleeping
because it's leaving the country there's
no way none of that makes sense they
weren't even dating yeah the last few
slides make no sense but what is
interesting is she's definitely being
catty because the last time she went was
with Selena well Selena was never
friends with Kendall again and while
this is happening Kendall's best friend
is with Selena's boyfriend I don't know
but why why would Selena Gomez need to
be on the other side of the planet
that's like why is that important to the
plan it's not right that's uh okay wait
why is Cody well let's see Cody Co
listened up you guys can too this photo
yes no I would open it up
and I would look at him and he'd be like
what is it
is it important and I'm like yeah
apparently Kendall asked Selena to come
on the New Year's Eve trip so that Haley
could be with Justin for New Year's Eve
isn't that incredible
so good that was so good it took me a
second to put that oh my God what's
happening right now you know Kelsey
obviously sat Cody down holding the
story the way I'm telling you and it
looks like he received it super well so
I hope to see you guys I don't believe
that somebody told me there's a test
after it
I don't believe that's true I don't
believe that's what happened I do but to
each their own
um there's enough evidence that uh you
know thank you there's been plenty of
stuff that I was on board without just
I'm not that's right it's a far fetched
the Dubai trip thing is a little
far-fetched yeah that's okay who's the
expert
exactly I don't feel like it would be
that far-fetched if you're a mega
celebrity you can be anywhere in the
world you want I'm sure they can just be
like oh let's go yeah right I mean they
definitely took a private plane I assume
yeah I don't I don't I I do feel like
it's a little yeah it is but I don't
even think it's insanely far-fetched but
girls be mean hey girl girl it's but if
they wanted to hang out and go out
together they could have done that
regardless I went on vacate together
okay I don't know I I'm not fully
against
neither am I about that and I'm just
offering that piece of information
all right I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry
um 49. okay okay
we're cruising no we're over halfway
through at this point we're committed
all right
let's go let's go
click slideshow in the top right there
you go red seed
Kendall and Justin then did a show a
shoot together for Vogue in March this
is obviously very publicly for Justin to
get back at Selena who's not friends
with Kendall anymore funny enough I
don't think they noticed this but
Kendall did I mean Justin did pretty
much the exact same photo shoot with his
wife Haley
um I feel like they could have changed
it not exactly I mean they're both on
pool chairs with the arm like this
this is by the way after he had sex with
like all of her sisters yeah
okay anyway back to our timeline it's
March 2015. Haley hooked up with Justin
over New Year's back
her best friend Kendall just did a Vogue
shoot with him and Haley favorites a
tweet calling Selena Gomez not hot okay
okay wait wait wait
start over
why on this Frame so it's March 2015. in
January yeah that was the Dubai trip and
the Haley hooks up with Justin okay
March or when was Vogue March same month
her best friend just did a shoot with
Justin Bieber for Vogue Haley's hair
best friend is Kendall Jenner
at this point in time
wait who's Kendall's best friend Haley
Haley okay
got it so Haley had just also hooked up
with Justin he's [__] all of them
seems like it
um Haley favorites a tweet calling
Selena Gomez that's just me yeah
and how old is Haley roughly at this
time you know
two years
two years old
so so early 20s late teens something
like that the the Tweet Says Selena
Gomez retweet for hot fave for not faves
wow
that's catty that's just that is me yeah
well it's because now she has her skin
in the game it was long ago I don't
understand why Haley was even mad like
originally yeah
choreographed dance I'm like why are you
even mad you're a non-factor it is her I
love you Sam well I'm
should I feel included I don't know no
Haley didn't know Justin or Selena when
she was like why would someone post
about a why would someone post a dance
like right wait did Haley comment on the
video yeah yeah yeah she had that tweet
that was like uh
calling me immature yeah yeah we're
talking yeah this was this was at least
10 years ago yeah at this point
and to the people calling me mature I
think it's immature taking the time to
learn a dance to someone posting it on
the internet oh I but I am curious why
people were calling her immature it
seems like she said something else but
I'm just wondering like why you get
involved at this point yeah she clearly
had stuff to say why oh oh spoiler word
oh come on
okay
I think she's just trying to take any
side that's on Justin's side
right yeah and I'm sure that when they
hooked up Justin probably towards some
[__] about Selena is the worst and
all this other you think oh absolutely
that's true well they all circle jerk
about how much they had they hooked up
at that point when she Haley made that
tweet though which tweet about the dance
no yeah they had no so she favorited the
tweet I thought she was team Jelena
though she was but it seems like she was
really just team Justin I'm getting lost
a little bit here guys yeah
yes yes I'm completely I'm sorry you are
not even trying to be okay do we want to
stop no no no I'm I'm with you I need to
know I'm following the main threads here
okay I don't like Kendall at all yeah
bro she sucks dude can I get another
Plum absolutely yeah
Plum yeah
oh never mind I'm on a plum run you want
one intermission
Olivia you're doing great thank you
rolling we're all in we're all in right
with the people who don't like drama I'm
sorry it won't be this crazy next time
uh the uh live viewership has gone up
significantly since we started this wait
what is it 42k right now oh people love
it I wonder if Selena will see this hold
on we need deeper we need deeper gossip
uh segment yeah I want to know who's
that girl in the background right there
which
in between uh Justin and and
who's that who is this that's Kendall
I'm just trying it's like Kylie in the
right photo that is Kylie that's Haley
that's Kendall that's Kendall that's
Justin that's Haley that's
it oh oh okay they have the same hair
yeah
should I keep going
yeah yeah I mean should we wait for cam
yeah he's here it's all good the next
slide I have a feeling is compelling it
is gonna be good maybe all right come
bring the plums cam yeah
baby
Selena did not attend Coachella with the
Jenners obviously Haley attended with
them and they were photographed hanging
out with Justin at this point Selena and
the Jenners and Justin they got to be
like ancient history you gotta like move
on with your life that was what I was
trying to say earlier it's like why are
you why is Selena does not befriend them
again okay okay it's over stop trying
she's cordial out events she's posed
with Kylie at like
to have Selena on here just to Spill the
whole team just to ask her anything for
her to be honest why didn't she do that
well because she says nothing and the
world thinks that she's bullied so she
should come on this show and talk about
it okay ready Selena
November 2015. so this was March last
last slide was Coachella in March we're
now November world's collided Justin's
AMA after party
what's happening
okay it's normal
um Justin was reportedly all over Selena
at his amas after party also there is
still something going on there with
Selena and Justin yes yes we're not done
with them I'm telling Selena she's got
to move on it's tough I know it's a
toxic it's tough [__]
um Haley and Selena both attended this
event Haley was photographed crying as
she left the event it was also her
birthday loser
okay I see why I see I guess I can see
why she would be pissed yeah at Selena
but yet again I gotta say these girls
are placed these girls are getting mad
at each other but Justin's the one being
a douche yeah yep
okay the [__] him cupcakes was posted
the next day by Haley
um oh my God she posted birthday
cupcakes from at Kendall Jenner LOL what
else are friends for they were
definitely about Justin I assume dude
these girls are such little snakes too
wait was it like oh like like [__] him
or was it like oh you should [__] it
you know what it was definitely possible
that is an interesting yeah I'm paying
attention here yeah because the data
that we've been given afterward would
show that your thesis is right I think
[__] it yeah I like your little note in
the corner what I bet they were bitter I
bet they were I bet they were oh we're
covered yeah it seems like these Jenners
and whatever they all it's like just a
matter of proximity to Selena right yes
Teddy
oh you're making Dinosaur Land
awesome
so fun
killing it Daddy
oh wow a dinosaur head volcano very
good oh it's a cup
fun
all right don't you think it's a little
two-faced how they're like they've just
been riding for Justin he's having sex
with all of them and then
all of a sudden they're posting [__] him
like come on this is one of my faves
um Justin released a duet with Halsey on
his new album purpose called the feeling
and the two got very cozy on stage at
Good Morning America and that week Haley
posted a Snapchat where she asks her
driver as a Halsey song is playing can
you change the station please that's a
little she's being a little drum drum I
think that's that's just right or PR
that's just a performance and the next
let's sell the records yeah a few days
later Halsey clowned on her did the same
thing with the same Cadence let's see
she's a little clownish for posting that
oh man
um can you change the station please oh
my God this is so embarrassing for all
of them can you change the station
please
um
thank you that is so cool but why did
Haley post that so was she in the middle
of a live jealous was she in the middle
of a live
it's a Snapchat oh okay so she went out
of her way yes mind you this is before a
tick tock so Duets like that didn't
happen right this was they put in the
work yeah they put in the work yeah
exactly but wait what Haley was just
like I ain't been doing like I said what
you said but because you're like Halsey
was like yeah she just pretty much
mocked her I could have done she could
have said something better than that the
way she started recording while the song
was on just as such cornball Behavior I
think the problem with her is that
they're in this bubble where they just
circle jerk about what house Eagle
Selena is
and this is like super embarrassing
shouldn't have posted that but I feel
like everyone's enabling each other to
be such [__] it's true it's true
I love this okay Haley follows that I
shouldn't say that word right it's
whatever should I hit the button no I
didn't call them [__] no no some of the
things they did were [__] sorry I'll
say it
um Haley follows Selena's biggest hate
account on Twitter what exposing SMG
Selena Marie Gomez March 2016. they
posted um Haley followed me and that's
showing what um this account
runs with a conspiracy theory that
Selena Gomez does not have Lupus which
is her autoimmune
oh wow that is [__] not yeah
that is so so mean doesn't Justin Bieber
have an autoimmune disease Lyme disease
he didn't I don't think he's gotten for
each other yeah he loves dicks
wait and he has ligma first of all
this is so mean I'd be surprised that
Justin is even like well that's what
fans are it's like dude she's so mean
I don't like this although I don't like
both of them so I'm glad they ended up
together like they both suck I love that
you guys are knowing this stuff as well
so I don't know how much of this I'll
retain but that's okay as long as you're
on the journey well are we going to have
like a
the other side the Haley perspective
because I feel like this is clearly a
little
said at the beginning that I have a
parasocial relationship with Miss and
that's fine yeah I'm not contending you
want to do it I know you're the resident
lover
oh yeah I've got a 400. wait would
anybody even want to present that I feel
like that's like uh career suicide yeah
Ian thoughts that's no I don't want any
of that smoke yeah I'm just because
Olivia has been sharing she's been
sending me information like websites I'm
sure my credit card information has been
stolen my identity from these sites but
ah there's some stuff that's very uh
what's the there's a phrase that I'm
seeing often which is like allegedly
this happened and that's the only
information deep deep assumptions
there's no hearsay follow up from where
it's come from who why where I don't
know but I'm not saying that means
Haley's innocent I don't want the smoke
like this whole claim that Justin had
sex with
the old ass sister what's her name I was
Courtney I was clear it was a legend it
was a rumor I have I showcase when
there's evidence he was like 14. he was
20.
there are some slides too like no one's
there was a slide earlier of like they
both wore bikinis in a photo six years
apart well that was some stuff I think
is about this is
the Vogue that was the Vogue photo shoot
where I was just like this is funny you
mean that they're both in pool chairs
yeah
um some of Haley's most interesting
coincidental copycat moments uh Selena
Gomez post by grace through faith by
grace through faith by grace through
faith happy Sunday and then Haley um if
I moved this you'll see it's exactly one
month after this one my grace is that an
expression by grace through faith I've
never heard that it's Selena Gomez's
Instagram bio as well so it's like she
that's not something that like a common
refrain that like Christians by grace
through faith happy Sunday we'll see Sam
you're a southerner have you ever heard
anyone say that uh
so it seems like it'd be a reference to
her pretty clearly yeah
um Jessica you know this ring in 2012.
Haley has this tattoo on her ring finger
which it could be it could be she's
married to Justin so that makes sense
um Selena has a g tattoo that she got
before Haley Selena stands for her
little sister Gracie we do not know what
Haley stands for it's a g for sure a
cursive G they both have cursive G's
behind their ear what that's weird yeah
same psychotic that's psycho what what
was wrong with her yeah what does that
stand for she's so crazy
we don't know what it stands it could
stand for something
Brandon women like yeah is this like a
Nexium thing yeah that's a good question
yeah if it's Justin doing it Instagram
yeah the same outfit is kind of crazy he
may have a nickname all those cult
leaders have a it's like some eyes wide
shot because because that's a stylist
decision thank you what's that outfit
they would know Selena Gomez wore this
on stage at the amas
Haley wore this how long after
it was after that's what I know this is
nut this doesn't doesn't Justin find
this all very weird behavior for his
wife people are curious it's weird I
think he gets honest Justin's there
maybe he likes when she dresses like his
ex because he's in love with her whoa
that's a conspiracy Jersey like she I
wonder if they have role play in bed he
goes pretend you're Selena no I'm sure
look at this you think I think
I think it was like so in love
pathetically she's in love with them
yeah okay how about go back go back and
then on the left what's that on the
bottom left that's also an identical
outfit it's a dress a turtleneck wait is
the hairstyle the same way Selena yes
also has a bow back though okay
um weird single white female Haley
followed all of Selena's friends at the
same time
um what if befriended Selena's closest
friends who aren't even in the industry
the real agents and have normal jobs
that's them hanging out with her we're
following all of them okay hold on hold
on hold on
so here is Selena hanging out with her
non-public Selena's not here so who so
who is Selena's friend that's Haley and
Selena's friend and Selena's friend no
but they couldn't be that close to
Selena if they she knows that's Raquel
her best friend
one of her other best friends why is she
doing that a lot of fans think that
Selena doesn't have good friends
so and who's the girl on the left this
girl uh Courtney have we considered that
Selena is just really annoying stop I
mean why like literally every friend
betrays her maybe she sucks no I'm just
putting a hypothesis for her I'm okay
I'm not saying that that's the case I'm
just wondering it's like if all of my
friends shouldn't have one loyal friend
yeah
that's [__] up
no one's saying it's her fault but it is
interesting how no one seems to be able
to stand her right and to be honest I
think she faked having lupus she was
diagnosed with bipolar in 2018 by the
way so she was probably unmedicated for
bipolar
um okay I mean the person that uh
donated her kidney also call her out or
do I have that mistake yeah that's
that's also uh is that in here it's not
in here
the kidney turned on her yeah that's a
whole as I was saying that's okay I'm
starting to wonder what's going on I am
the girl who gave the kidney turned on
her literally someone friendly enough
with her we haven't gotten to that yet
yeah I don't think but I do have
this app or website that's giving us the
option to stop spying right
what is that it's whatever
um service allowed you to see when
someone follows someone yeah it's like
it's like a search it's like a oh that's
so you can see somebody's followers
I'm sorry that was
now this is crazy she followed all three
at the same time yes and then was
hanging out with them but what's wrong
with these okay Selena with them that's
like last year that is so psycho why is
this is so psychotic these are not we're
friends in the industry
they might have just measured each other
in the same place so weird
all of them yeah or one of them
well that's everybody here is saying
Taylor Taylor Taylor a lot of people
think that Taylor and Selena like who's
Taylor Taylor Swift yeah uh if you guys
want to listen Taylor Swift has a song
that's probably about Selena Gomez
called Dorothea and it's a beautiful
Showcase of friendship Dorothea oh so
you're saying Taylor has stood by her
yes okay well I lost that yeah I love
Taylor shoes because I again I was only
going off of the information you're
presenting me I don't know anything
about it any of this so when all you're
showing me is like oh she had these
friends and they all betrayed her and
then these friends all betrayer I'm
starting to see a pattern here
except for Taylor Swift except for
Taylor Swift Taylor Swift come on the
show clear things up
okay Justin Selena feud in his comments
August 2016. he began dating Sophia
Richie when Justin was 22 she was just
17 turning 18 that month but she was 17
at this time he was posting her all over
her social media fans expressed concern
Justin threatened to private his
Instagram Selena weighed in she
commented if you can't handle the hate
stop posting pictures of your girlfriend
LOL it should be special between you two
only don't be mad at your fans they love
you they were there for you before
anyone she posted that which is on the
photo it's messy yeah but also think
about how how hurt she probably is after
all of these years yeah but that's crazy
that's why also she may be just trying
to protect the girl too because she went
through it herself oh that's giving her
a lot of credit I'm on board
Lena sounds
songs
the kidney girl I don't have all of that
in there but do you want me to tell you
yes okay so Selena Gomez
um
got a kidney donated by her best friend
Francia rasa best friend IRL yes Francia
rasa why did she need kidney from lupus
lupus okay yeah was this she part of her
fan club or something is that oh that I
don't know I know that Francia was on a
TV show called like American teenager or
something
um after the kidney was given to Selena
she went on like news broadcast she uh
honored her at billboard women music of
the year she said like I think Francia
should be getting this award she saved
my life and then um a few years later
um Selena said in an interview that
Taylor was like one of her only friends
in the industry and Francia responded
commented on the e-news thing that said
that because Francia was in a TV show
and so and she gave her a kidney and she
said interesting
and then unfollowed Selena couldn't
maybe she's reading a little far into it
right I think it's more Selena in the
industry she meant like super super like
super famous they're really friends
she's not gonna bail because of one
comment well a lot of people speculate
that um after Selena got her kidney she
was drinking and Francia was a little
bit angry with her that's fair it's like
yo I gave you my organ that sounds kind
of [__] and so yeah
can is there a return policy on the
kidney 30 days it's too late it was 20
2017. I want it back
okay
keep reading this is good [__] okay
Justin Bieber responded to Selena in the
comments by saying it's funny to see
people that used me for attention and
still try to point the finger this way
shut up that's [__] yeah you cheated
on her like 20. I love that celebs used
to be fine I know and then he says I'm
not one for anyone receiving hate hope
you all can be kind to my friends and
each other yeah
[Music]
funny slime
making slime
yeah what happened why aren't celebs
messy like this anymore or are they
because they didn't understand that
social media was like forever forever
yeah
um so Selena responds funny how the ones
that cheated multiple times are pointing
the finger at the ones that were
forgiving and supportive no wonder fans
are mad sad all love
that is so messy it's a little Tupac so
now it's January the weekend is involved
in the [__] hell yeah this [__] was
funny to me okay
January 2017. Selena and the Weekender
spotted kissing uh the weekend is Bella
hadid's Ex two weeks after this could be
coincidental but a lot of people have
pointed out that they think that Haley
is shading Selena by saying two weeks
after she started dating Bella's ex wait
sorry who could possibly be cuter than
Bella Hadid literally nobody may I add a
detail I have to go to the restroom yeah
okay detail that yeah uh Justin Bieber
was asked by the paparazzi has he
listened to the new weekend album and
Justin Bieber was like no I'm not
[__] with that or something along
those lines and then it came out
publicly that the weekend and Selena
were dating yes get [__] owned Biebs
so somebody's listening to it so uh
presumably he said that because they
were together right yeah and he was not
cool with them but apparently he thinks
that she's not allowed to date anybody
so she said wait oh sorry who could be
cuter and it's just a video of her in a
bathtub yeah I mean that's definitely
shade okay I have no problem believing
that after all this [__] October don't
you [__] tell me they're hanging out
again October 2017 oh my God Helena
break up and then Justin and Selena
reconnect through Hillsong church
it's like where all the celebrities go
like the kind of the crazy church is it
a cult kind of cool wait what do they do
there church they sing
they're just crazy very close with their
pastors
wait this is so interesting what the
[__] didn't it come out that like the
the pastor of Hillsong that cheated on
his wife or something I think that there
was some controversy they made them get
like cheese tattooed on the background
yeah what the [__] is going on with
these celebrities Hillsong Church where
they all hang out and Praise Jesus yeah
so since the last time they were
together Selena had undergone her kidney
transplant the two had grown up people
hoped
that things would be easier
trouble in Paradise December Selena TMZ
reports that Selena Gomez and Justin
Bieber are in couples therapy because of
Haley Baldwin because she saw that he
was texting yo this is the worst cut
beavers ever had go down can you go down
or is it cut off the must combo is crazy
that comb over is wild as [__] dude
bring it back that's that hill song yes
he has such nice hair too like why I
think it's after he bleached it so he
had to like cut it all off just falling
out yeah because he bleached it like
2015. that's a wild look dude hell no
Valentine's Day
it's therapy they still seem happy they
celebrated Valentine's Day together at
the Montage Beverly Hills Hotel
um just a side note this isn't really it
doesn't have to do with like the story
story but a year later uh Justin was
photographed outside this hotel with his
wife and he was crying I don't think it
has it's it has anything to do with
Selena Gomez I just think that it's a
weird coincidence
okay jelena's last birthday March Selena
makes it Instagram official with Justin
for the first time in years posting a
birthday message for her then boyfriend
March 1st someone I know happens to be
super cool is born Boom the World Went
Crazy
Jelena takes a break she's not a great
birthday wish
no no
not really at all Jelena takes a break
March 16th just a week after Selena
seemingly inferred she and Justin were
going to be together for good the two
announced they'd be taking a break then
two months later Justin begins seeing
Haley Baldwin again son of a [__]
she was right real quick I mean Dan just
missed like I was watching slides I I
pulled it up on my phone I was watching
we might have to go back nope we don't
have to go back we don't need that yeah
okay have fun
okay wait hold on sorry Zach can you
give me a plum
are you serious how many pounds are you
eating I'm just hungry
plums all right I mean this this is
taking a while so we see how many plums
you eaten during this presentation is
your third
and I feed them all day you just see
plums you know anything else
oh dinner later how many plums you eat
in a day
five
five Plum this is maybe my fourth today
are you constipated no is
are they good this season they're good
right now I think so I don't know I just
requested every time we do like office
uh yeah grocery runs yeah Plum yes opens
and protein shakes so two months later
she was right she was right to be
worried about her she was trying to get
in there the whole damn time yeah she
has been so she was like 12. yeah
daily is engaged one month later what
the [__] wait go back go down as well
quick yeah think about how long this
slideshow was and how quick that was how
painful that must have been
can you go back one real quick okay
nevermind
so they so two months after their final
breakup
they're dating and then one month later
they're engaged yeah I didn't realize it
was that yeah short of a time it was
crazy
what is her t-shirt say cherry that's a
great song by Zach
Lewisville
so so he was just gushing over go back
yeah he's like you're the only one for
me
I wouldn't want to spend it with anyone
else I wonder if they're bonding over
Jesus though because she's religious
yeah it's Jesus and I'm totally not mad
that Celine hooked up with the week
of the week but that happened already
yeah yeah but not their couple name
being jaylie yo I didn't even think
about it in jail wait wait wait wait I
have more questions go back
but Selena was at the church so she's
also religious yeah
so they're all they're all yes
yourself you have to see my slime I'll
be gonna come together
love it
yeah
those are those are contents
just put them down there's liquid in
there thank you Bob it's not a toy even
though it looks like it I know there's
liquid in it it's okay you didn't do
anything wrong you're good you're
good yeah
you get Daddy you're like what he's like
he's good he's good see you in a little
bit bye-bye did they have some flying
Nikes him and Bruce
it looks like a fun thing to play with
are we ready so wow okay so so I know
that like they're pretty religious
Selena is a religious Christian yeah so
that she doesn't really have that edge
either then like yeah they're all
they're all indeed so does Mr Baldwin
her Dad too right
yeah he's deep he's like a Maga guy too
doesn't surprise me okay real quick
before we get on the slide his shirt is
[__] me I like that I just that's
awesome
like that is fit he's got like a Brad
Pitt thing going on 10 out of 10. yeah
look I won't deny it I agree it's good
okay Jaylee tied the knot legally at a
courthouse wedding the next month wait
did you get it was a courthouse wedding
and then they had a formal ceremony a
year later Jesus is everywhere they
dated for a month got engaged and then a
month later they're married yeah
after dating Selena Gomez for eight
years on and off no do you think they
were
they were obviously having intercourse
before yeah they were hooking up
definitely or do you think they might
have been soaking I know
I know what's soaking
it's when you put it in but you just
don't uh you just let it suck it seems
like sexy but what do I know no it is
penetration definitely sex yeah okay you
gotta put it in and take it out we are
almost done I think we have less than 10
um October 2018 Selena goes into
treatment
and Justin took this pretty hard he's
photography for
um mental health this is when she got
diagnosed with bipolar and how soon
after they got married speculate that
it's substance abuse as well so that
could be the kidney thing where she's
like yo I gave you my kidney and you're
using drugs yeah so um but how soon
after the marriage is this
this is on October Poor House wedding
was August same year okay
um he was photographed crying the same
day and it's reported that Haley Bieber
was seen driving past Selena Gomez's
house with her pastor's wife why hold on
I don't know
how do we know he's crying about that
we don't
just a picture of him crying well it was
the day that it was announced okay it
was like photograph crying all over them
so he was photographed crying and the
same day Haley Bieber
was allegedly seen driving past her
house with her pastor's wife while
Justin was with the pastor with whose
pastor's wife they are Pastor from
Hillsong Church
of all their pasture yeah yeah Selena
then laid low for the next year so why
are they driving by your house
some people think that it's just to see
if she's actually in treatment but I
don't know
what the pasture is what she's getting
involved in this yeah or they're praying
maybe for her going to drive by prey
intimate together
you know what anything's possible
anything
this is insane how this is all
documented like they got a picture of
them driving passes out like what the
[__]
I've never seen a drive-by prayer they
should swap roll down the window hey yo
Hail Mary
here right okay A year later Selena
releases her comeback single lose you to
love me which is clearly about her toxic
relationship with Justin Bieber and her
moving on and healing Haley 34 minutes
after the song was released posted a
screenshot of her listening to the song
I'll kill you in her defense the song
came out a few weeks before this that's
crazy that's insane because the first
line of that song is if there's [__]
around you they better be blood
like
I love summer also just she's not even
saying like oh I'm coming for your man
Haley's just like I [__] hate you
it's like she's trying to move on with
her life in Selena's song it does say in
two months you replaced us like it was
easy so people did get on Haley
but I don't think she should have posted
this is Sicilian message yeah for sure
yeah
Haley posting that and the song in
general resulted in her getting a bunch
of hate most of it was so unnecessary
nasty all of you take things too far
none of you should send hate comments
ever Selena she's reaping what she saw
I mean it sounds like to me I don't know
what I I don't know what kind of comment
she was getting about
um she was in an Instagram live she
seemingly comes to his defense without
stating her name she says I do not stand
for women tearing other women down and I
will never be by that so please be kind
that's just a disclaimer she was all
about it I have to say I like her hair
here I also like her hair here pretty
and you know Haley was like man [__] her
for putting up that video I bet yeah
she's done this a few times too right
yeah yeah rare album release party
January 2020. the week that Selena
released her comeback album rare which
is all about her Newfound happiness and
healing Selena celebrated at Craig's
West Hollywood for Jimmy Legos she got
yeah literally yeah she got everyone
toasters with their face burned into one
because one of the lines in rare is
burning toast in the toaster she got a
cake wait hold on what about the toaster
yeah one of the lines in her song is
burning toast in the toaster so she got
everybody like custom toasters
this was a party what's on the toaster
whose face is the the people who
attended her party each one got a
customizable yeah cute isn't that
awesome amazing
January 2020 Haley shows up to Craig's
Los Angeles at the same time with
Madison Beer who is also friends with
Selena Selena unfollowed Madison that
night on Instagram but then she
re-followed after fans notice hold on
he's in Madison Beer always with JB as
well
um well scooter signed Madison and so JB
at one time it was just Madison and JB
on Scooter's label so she is close with
you know I think Scooter's a mastermind
behind all this he's a he's a
manipulative I know Taylor Swift hates
him yeah and so I hate him I love that
okay so wait let me Swifty Central over
here
so Haley crashes rare release party that
was the party we just saw yeah she
showed up to that party did you get a
toaster yeah
she showed up to the restaurant invited
yeah well no she sat at her own table
with her friends oh it wasn't so mean
wait once they close down the whole
restaurant if it's a private party
[Music]
Haley is so [__] mean girl you need
to grow up and move on reported on this
we know Dumas isn't always accurate but
style icon is a stretch seeing as it is
more of an affiliation that made her
client a bit more popular that would be
her husband before even as her stylist
no one talked about her client The
Stylist also tries to be best friends
with said client can you decode uh I
will once we get to it yeah but who's
who so style icon would be Haley and
then stylist is her stylist okay
um
this stylus also tries to be best
friends with said clients so Haley's
stylist apparently tries to be best
friends with her she once befriended a
girl who is close with the famous
ex-girlfriend of her client's husband
which is she got information from
Selena's friend who was friends with
Haley as well that's just the game of
telephone at that point so well I don't
know they ended up at the same room it
is ugly specific what do you want me to
do you want reported this so get it so
get on to the point because I see oh I'm
sorry go ahead she wants no no I'm sorry
oh sorry do you wanna go let's hear
where this is going okay she uh got
inside information about a party the ex
was having at Craig's then dressed her
client to the nines called paps to show
up and have her client fully upstage the
excess celebration the ex was devastated
and so was the girl that was duped by
the stylist
it's all gossip yeah
but I believe it yeah me too
2018 Haley attempted to trademark Bieber
beauty just a few months after Gomez
founded rare Beauty
I feel like that's turning the knife
about her having that last name no I
think she got I don't think she cares
okay I feel like a lot of people just
try to get trademarks but they're not
okay
Kardashians yeah okay sure yeah Baldwin
well it was rejected so yeah
oh
the rust palette
we're at today so no oh we're in 2023.
it is not insane nor is it a stretch to
wonder if this was a jab it's Selena
Gomez okay so now decode this because I
I saw people talking about this and
saying it's a stretch people are looking
too far into it so now let's let's wait
Selena Gomez got an immense amount of
hate and disgusting people saying that
she was fat and that she had gained
weight okay because she went on vacation
posted a photo of herself in a bikini
and she also by the way also medicine
yes she has spoken about it but she's on
steroid yes
so
so Kendall
Haley and this girl Justine Skye who
says that she was hacked but she had put
that was on her Snapchat saying making
tick tocks every day like you haven't
got a shitty makeup Ranch run just whack
as hell clearly about Selena but she
said she was hacked was she making tick
tocks
Selena yeah she makes she loves Tick
Tock okay so those three girls we know
Kendall's history with Selena we know
Haley's history with Selena we know that
she put this girl Justine potentially
hates Selena they say in a video of an
old sound that hasn't been used in a
minute I'm not saying she deserved it
but God's timing is always right and
then so what's this one in the middle
this I never comment on this type of
thing no no the picture this is from
that that's from the video yeah
and it was posted on accident by the
third girl no this was posted by Haley
Bieber publicly okay this I'm just
telling you who this girl is okay okay
okay yeah so when people obviously were
like
is this about Selena Gomez is this about
Selena Gomez Haley wrote I never comment
on this type of thing but we were just
having a girls night and did a random
Tick Tock fun it's not direct today
so you're right the case closed she was
definitely sharing it
and she's so mean she's such a [__]
mean nasty person or this eyebrow gate
few days later Selena Gomez says in her
story that she accidentally laminated
her eyebrows too much and Kylie Jenner
and Haley Bieber post this this was an
accident and then she tags Haley Bieber
I don't get this why are they care why
are they [__] on her eyebrows I
think they're trying to sub tweet in the
most vague way possible maybe it's just
mean to be mean though yeah what is the
middle what was the middle Tick Tock the
whole thing
it says this was an accident I'm not
saying this one no no no go back to the
next one the middle one it's just a
photo on her on her uh Instagram story
and she wrote this was an accident on
top of her eyebrows yes that's [__]
beautiful what I love you guys and then
what's the one on the right and then
this was her second post on her story
she's going
she's not in the best hell you guys won
you got the guy she's been that's my
thing
100 and she didn't really win because
he's not no prize yeah but like
literally I don't know okay going into
this I thought a lot of these Selena
fans were just people who watched her on
Disney growing up and they were just
being extra but after seeing all this I
gotta say I think more of what it was
was that her and Justin were like the It
couple and this group of Mean Girls
wanted to be in on that and just have
been bullying her ever since
I literally think you guys this is this
is everything this is so [__] up that
they're still messing with her like yeah
there's no and you're a grown ass woman
like shame on you Haley Bieber you're
disgusting
okay so a few days later Haley's old
stylist he deleted since all of his
photos with her this was one of his
posts Selena Gomez he posted I hate
Selena Gomez all of Selena's fans were
reporting it and it was taken down by
Instagram and he who's another that's
one of her old stuff why does everyone
hate her though back to what Dan was
saying yeah why does everybody hate
Selena Gomez probably because like I
said they're all in the same group in
Hollywood
this guy what does he have to gain from
going Publix
I said what I said that's Haley's all
stylist what an awful career move to be
a celebrity stylist and be like I hate
Selena Gomez he's private now on
Instagram [__] idiots
so wait go back and then he posted just
simping for Halo no no this is just to
show that he knows her he's posted for
her birthday it's her birthday yeah 130
likes why would you do that yeah okay so
no I don't think Selena should be
scrutinized too heavily for being fed up
and defending her friend on a tick tock
or having a weak moment in publicly
showcasing sadness about her ex who's
married to someone who has been very
nasty about her and her that's to put it
mildly yeah so some of the the comments
that people were getting mad at saying
like Selena's fueling The Bullying
that's headed Haley's way is she said so
sorry my best friend is and continues to
be one of the best in the game on a tick
tock of an old clip of Haley gagging at
the prospect of Taylor Swift okay hold
on hold on
Selena commented yeah on what on a tick
tock of an old clip of Haley gagging
about Taylor
okay why did she do that because she
does she I mean Taylor Selena's best
friend I assume that what if she doesn't
like the association yeah I'm sorry
does that whole camp
or whatever dude I mean I haven't seen
them Associated dude how are you even
gonna go against Taylor Swift like
that's just a l no that is the biggest
fan base in the universe you might as
well go against BTS at that point all
right literally so she publicly gagged
yeah well that's what well to be fair
that's what Taylor did to Justin maybe
that was a response maybe that maybe
that's actually a great point
yeah so she responded
Taylor's the best yeah okay and then
another one is she commented on a tick
tock where I will say the girl called
Haley a mean girl in it but then she
went on to talk about how much she loves
Selena and she shouldn't be getting hate
for being for gaining weight and Selena
commented on it it's okay I don't let
these things get me down be nice to
everyone I would just like to make the
statement that defense and offense are
two drastically different positions
Selena's taking the high road I think so
too but a lot of people what was the
video commented that on a girl called
Haley a mean girl and then went on to
say that people need to shut up and stop
she was defending so she was defending
Selena Gomez
I don't think she should even comment on
this [__] she just gotta move on dude
these are like adults now like they used
to be kids when it started they're not
[__] kids anymore well that's why
after all this stuff happened Selena
went on Tick Tock live and she was just
like I'm 30.
um I'm taking a social media break thank
you girl yeah
yeah time to move so Selena says to
Cease the hate and it must nobody wins
if a beautiful relationship is sabotage
now Haley and Justin are so happy it
seems
um if you love Selena then love that
she's happy and love that she's probably
happy that her ex is Happy
um maybe I don't know uh Selena clearly
wants to move on not be tied I want that
I wish bad things for Haley though it's
hard to interrupt I don't like her
um real quick uh just because this I
could be wrong with this slide we seem
to be moving towards the wrap up here
right yeah yeah this is like last uh
maybe you could comment on this
um I just saw in the chat um
why does Selena liking and commenting on
random Haley hate that's what that's
because that connected to it said Haley
is a mean girl and then the girl went on
to talk about no one should
say that she is ugly because she gained
weight Okay blah blah it is a little
catty for her to be commenting on random
Haley Bieber hate videos and that's why
I don't think she should be scrutinized
too heavily based on previous data that
we have to Showcase what everybody has
done to one another but to be fair I
feel Haley is done far worse she's so
mean and recently yeah she probably
feels like her voice is silence because
she just get ganged up on so this is the
only thing she can say I'm sure she
wants to say a lot more yeah she's with
Justin for how long who knows what she's
being threatened years you know yeah
eight years yeah
dude Haley is she just so mean like I
understand that you know everyone messed
up but like of recently when they're
considered adult she was just so [__]
mean for no reason yeah so so okay go
ahead with sorry I interrupt um nobody
wins if you guys send hate nobody send
hate to Haley that is literally so
stupid
um but
I'm saying if any of you want to call
Selena Gomez a bully
now
everybody in this office that didn't
know this story that's what kind of
started this is modern people saying
she's a bully though why is she not
saying anything Haley blah blah blah
they
people were putting Selena in the
villain position in this instance that
happened this year especially people in
this office and I was trying to switch
the situation
the I'm not saying she deserved it but
God's timing is always right but Selena
how is Selena bowling because she had
commented on tick tocks after that oh
she was being catty about uh yeah Bieber
eight videos yeah got it
um fans need to stop fans want everybody
to be happy that they're fans of it's
done this is the Treaty of Versailles
[Laughter]
wow can you read those yes Selena posted
first she posted this just happened yeah
I first of all can't even imagine how
painful it was to write Haley Bieber
sorry I'm gonna talk about it
um people were saying that it was caddy
for her okay
yeah did this happen last month this is
like okay
um
uh she wrote Haley Bieber reached out to
me and let me know she has been
receiving death threats and such hateful
negativity this isn't what I stand for
no one will have to experience hate or
bullying I've always advocated for
kindness and really want this all to
stop a lot of people came for Selena
because of that because of this message
why they were saying why did she have to
include Haley Bieber reached out to me
why why is she saying that he'll arrest
her for help oh they're going with it
through a [__] wait but that's that's
they're right they're right there was
something there to mentioning that she
reached out because it's humiliating her
I mean I would have done it too like
she's this girl who's been rolling her
she's calling my ass telling me to tell
my fans to chill out yeah like okay girl
that's rich I'll do it but I'm gonna say
you [__] called me
so Haley posted then I want to thank
Selena for speaking out as her and I
have been discussing the last few weeks
how to move past this ongoing narrative
between her and I the last few weeks
have been very hard for everyone
involved and millions of people are
seeing so much hate around this which is
extremely harmful shut up while social
media is an incredible way to connect
and build community mode girl I don't
need you to qualify social media
it's like this will only create extreme
division instead of bringing people
together things can always be taken out
of context
that's true let's keep that in mind
during this presentation sure or
construe differently than they were
intended we all need to be more
thoughtful about what we post and what
we say I agree including myself I agree
in the end I believe love will always be
bigger than hate and negativity and
there is always an opportunity to meet
each other with more empathy and
compassion I don't think this is tree of
her size like people think no I don't
think so either
this is just a cold this is a cold war
you know what the Treaty of Versailles
created right World War II [__] Amen
brother so who's Hitler
yeah yeah I don't know is a tangential
involved yeah so that's at the end
that's it that's it okay
holy [__]
[Applause]
it's been a uh Selena Gomez fan I
relayed some information to Olivia that
she was shocked by yes and that is I
have a signed headshot from Selena
obsessed wait you do wait why but you
were the biggest hater of the story
not necessarily I just feel I was I
didn't understand it and I was ignorant
so I do apologize
um but uh when she was on Wizards of
Waverly Place
um
I got a signed the head shopping
[Applause]
I will say while Selena is by no means
innocent and all this
these girls were staying straight mean
girl the [__] out of her I think so too
and like the expectation that she
wouldn't have any moments like you're
expecting her to be a saint like a
perfect Saint while these girls just
[__] try to ruin her life I don't
know
hell no and Selena if you are watching
there's an open invitation to come on
the show anytime
well done
all right
okay holy [__] how long did it take you
to put that together or was it all by
memory
um a week holy [__] dude that was in
wait a week I thought you've been
working on this for months
I feel like you've been working on the
PowerPoint for a while
I think I started after we had talked
about it so whenever that was she's
using the alpha day method so like it's
bro I need more of those really that was
like
so great thank you so I love that that
was so much
he loves a messy drama he thrives on it
and this is definitely messy so I can
see why you were enthralled living for
it yep
wow Olivia I'm so impressed that was so
much fun thank you it's all gone Olivia
well done
you know we went there with the
expectation that we were gonna bail but
my God I don't think you got a single no
in fact I would even appoint you as the
the uh drama curator I'd be obsessed
with that drama historian I love it I
want another one dumb
Friday oh we have a guest Friday Friday
tomorrow take your time make another
mask another one wow I'm glad and the
audience liked it too how fun was that
what it sure did I mean um you know I
think it took a little when I was keep
an eye on the chat and like I that's why
I shouted out at the beginning like just
to make it clear the goal here is to
make it interesting to people that are
not participating in it because I think
people are getting frustrated that we
were asking so many questions but at the
end of the day I think us asking
questions got us engaged in the
narrative and actually interested and so
you know it all worked out that's the
whole point of the bed I don't want to
explain that people are so annoying
no questions stop participating by the
way I sent you what you I think the show
you were talking about when you said the
Magnificent life of Jeff and Cody oh you
sent me that yeah let's see the mag them
yeah this is what I was thinking of The
Magnificent life of Jeff and Cody my
boys right
awesome
oh it's funny well wow wow wow wow what
a fun up man that was awesome thank you
we want
and I mean we're ready to wrap it up
here it's 4 40. what how long we've been
going we've been going for three hours
36 minutes oh yeah 59 seconds yeah
thank you so much guys that was a really
fun Journey
thank you to uh Olivia thank you to
everybody thank you to Teddy who was uh
sharing with us
um tomorrow is Thursday which means
leftovers will be here tomorrow morning
and big news
what about
uh Donald Trump was arrested this week
oh yeah that big news
yeah we have a lot to discuss tomorrow
we have a lot to do and then on Friday
we have um Terry Joe that's right so fun
so excited
I heard Cherry feels been talking smack
on Tick Tock she's like what did she say
yeah let's watch it funny
he's like uh he doesn't know what he's
getting himself into boy I should do my
Southern accent with her
just a couple of good old southern Folk
here's Terry Jill talking smack
I don't know how to open this because
it's like directly
uh embedded here I got it I just
downloaded it
wait
wait why is a recording of a did they
delete it because her comments are
impossible to get dude she's she's on
another one it was a tick tock live like
yeah she does tick tock lives and you
can but I just know this video is the
one that was set in chat
okay here it is
oh my God Apple what the [__] why is it
so small
okay enjoy guys
hold on I I got it I got it all right
I'll pull it up on my screen lit
I got it
um
because I will be on Friday afternoon
that's all I want that's all I ask I
just want the gospel girl
describe the gospel
all right guys great episode thank you
everyone for being here we'll see you
tomorrow for leftovers Friday for Terry
Joe great week of content for a change
finally
also Sergeant members yesterday's
episode got blocked interestingly it's
back up now but you know it wasn't Mac
Miller that blocked it it was [__]
Nintendo for the trailer they showed I
showed their trailer and they [__]
blocked wait
that's not
I don't think he's so cool I saw that it
was the Mac Miller okay I'm wrong then
it was both I think but wait I think it
was Button the Nintendo claimed us the
other one was just a claim because what
happened was the Nintendo or the Mac
Miller one got edited out
and then I noticed that it was still
claimed but it was viewable right so it
was Nintendo that was blocking us
because they showed their [__] no you
have it I have it backwards
okay
that is crazy that Nintendo claimed
claim for showing your trailer yeah
stupid idiots so so dumb so dumb
all right I gotta go uh
uh thank you guys so much we'd love to
be able to see you tomorrow God bless
stay blessed yada yada yada and we stand
Selena in this studio government
definitely and Taylor Swift in fact both
of you all come on together we'll make
I would love that don't be a big deal
we'll just you know that's big of you to
extend that off I do I I have the open
offer them a platform yeah
all right love you guys see you tomorrow
[Music]